one hello hello why am i awake at this time my sleep schedule is beyond fucked right now literally right after the sponsor i i didn't even eat dinner by the way i like passed out at at 8 p.m i was done i think it was not even it was like i think it was like 7 30 to 8 p.m i was like i'm done because i was awake at like four in the morning last night and obviously um I am awake at 3.30 in the morning this time.
It's not, it's not doing so well.
My sleep schedule is not very healthy, right?
I am like, like, I'm perpetually just, I'm always trying to catch up on sleep debt at the moment.
So this is not good.
I also have yet to touch Street Fighter, which is also not good.
Because, okay, so there is a reason why I have yet to touch Street Fighter.
Let me like get Marvel Rivals on the screen real quick before I talk about Street Fighter.
a completely different game.
Give me a sec.
Let me change my screen real quick.
Like I said, I don't know why it does that.
It always like changes my monitor to my second monitor, which is so fucking annoying.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
My varavos.
All right.
So the reason why I have...
yet to touch Street Fighter is because my coaching session doesn't start until Tuesday and I am in a little bit of a predicament because I talked to Justin you know I'm on first-name bases with the the Wazler but mr.
Wong and he told me that Zangief got a bit of a nerf so I was like that's not fun you know that's not like you know like that's not fun having a a grappler being nerfed so um so then I ask nephew who is also for this one why am I playing street fighter I have a street fighter tournament uh this week that's officially sponsored by Capcom so um you know I have less than six days to learn how to play street fighter again um which I should have learned street fighter like you know maybe two like a week ago but I was so busy and I am also very busy this week as well so last week I was so busy this week it's also the same type of business so it's it it doesn't stop um but then now I have to fit in um street fighter practice so basically I was like okay this is unfortunate so I was like asking nephew uh who is my actual coach or the uh yeah why am I not playing street fighter right now instead of my rivals because I want to be not look there's a lot of I'm very greedy.
There's a lot of things that I want.
And I'm very greedy.
And I also want to be nominated for Marvel Rivals in the Streamer Awards.
So that's why we're not playing Street Fighter right now.
I'm already guaranteed in the Street Fighter tournament.
But I'm not guaranteed into the Marvel Rivals nomination.
So I'm trying to secure it right now.
Anyway.
Anyway, so I was talking to Nephew, and, you know, I'll say this on stream too, so I'll repeat this story, because, you know, some people don't watch me on Twitch, and it's also 4 in the morning, so I feel like a lot of people aren't watching me right now.
Like, a lot of the main dragoons aren't really watching me right now, because they might be actually, you know, doing normal things like sleeping.
But, but anyway, so I was talking to Nephew, and I was like, what do I play?
I play Zangief or like do I learn something new because like at this point I might as well be a new player because I forgot everything about Zangief like I legitimately don't even know like what the controls are or anything so um so I was just like what do I do and okay let me read you so Nephew was like did you like Zangief and I literally was like well I only picked them because I asked chat which character would tilt my opponent the most like and easy to abuse I'm really like I would like to play the character that is most easily abusable and will make the enemy team very mad like that's I don't care who it is as long as it does the the two criteria that I wanted um yeah I just want to play something that's easiest to abuse and make people the most angry.
That's all I want.
I don't care.
Because he was like, are you attached to Zangief?
And I was like, I just want, I'm just here for the easy ride, you know?
And to make others suffer.
So at that time, that's when Zangief was suggested to me to learn.
Because he fits that criteria.
But then he got nerfed.
So I was like, what the fuck do I play?
Do I still play Zangief?
he was like, okay, here are some picks that you could do.
You gotta keep playing Zane Keep because even though he's nerfed, it doesn't really affect until higher level, but his damage output is a bit lower.
I was like, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
If I'm fucking trying, if I like grapple you and then throw your head to the ground, it should still give you a concussion.
It shouldn't give you like a little oopsie thing.
I should be close to breaking your fucking neck um so i was like i don't know if i like that so and then he was like okay but there's uh but if you really want a character that's very easily abusable and will make new players really mad you should try honda um and then he was like but we also have jp so but he was like but i don't know if you can do jp because he was trying to say my brain is he didn't imply that my brain was too small with JP but like he was like there's a lot you can get very overwhelmed as a new player which I took it as I'm too stupid to play JP so so and he's right he's right I am too stupid to play JP if he has more than four buttons like it's over for me like because I legit told him I was like I okay this is what I wrote to him I tend to just learn three the four moves and then just and just spam it until it works i'm not the best with executing combos and then nephew was like yeah i think honda would be the best fit for you like
so um yeah so so that jp has too much apparently you have to have like a really fucking giant ass brain to play jp and i don't think i can do that because if it's more than four moves it's over for me um so yes now i'm in a difficult position on whether or not I play Honda or keep with Zangief because apparently um um apparently Honda is like he's not good at high level but like for the new bracket like it's very easy to like um it's very hard to counter Honda in the beginner bracket so because it's literally four moves apparently for modern Honda I just have to press one button and he does his entire like combo he does he does the combo that um that tilts people the most and like if it's and it's just one button so i was like that sounds good like that sounds great like yeah for yeah just one button and he does this entire like charge combo i don't know what the fuck he meant by that but like i heard like um you can just hit that one button and then he does it all and i was like oh
that sounds really fun like one button let's go yeah so now i'm in a predicament so that's why i haven't like played street fighter because i don't know if i'm staying with zangif or if i'm playing honda and because there's another reason why i don't know because i will reveal my secret my secret coach I still haven't like been this is why I haven't had a schedule yet because I also like I'm trying to like We're trying to fit our schedules together with my other coach And I will reveal the secret coach at my 4 30 in the morning marvel rival stream To show the other dragons they're missing out that shouldn't have went to bed Also don't don't listen I that's a joke guys please have a healthier sleep schedule than me That's a joke,
but this is for all the Asia dragoons and EU dragoons and also the ones that have just as much of a fucked up schedule as me.
So I got in touch with Big Bird because, you know, like, because we're the bird family.
Like Angry Bird, Big Bird, Doki Bird.
So I got in touch with Big Bird and he's down to do a coaching session with me.
It'll be like 9 p.m.
PST.
I don't know the day yet.
Because we're waiting for his schedule right now.
Because he's like trying to figure out like what is the best day.
And that is also why my schedule isn't out yet.
Because like I also having an extra coaching session with Big Bird.
Yes.
Ada.
I think that's like his other.
His not fun name call.
I get to see.
I told you.
I told you I'm officially in the bird family.
Now I just need anger.
bird and i've collected them all i've collected all the birds uh yeah his normie name yeah so um so uh this is also why my schedule um isn't um isn't like out yet because i uh he told me that he'll let me know today uh when uh he'll let me know today and when when he can like when we his schedule the session it'll be either he said it'll be either wednesday or thursday so i don't know man this week is like super fucking packed it's also why i don't know if i'll have a rest week a rest day at all because it's like back to back to back and even saturday i have like an apex hide and seek tournament which by the way i should really check up on that because i have no idea if like it's this week so but i feel like i have not heard anything about it so that's a little concerning.
I should look at that server real quick.
Give me a second.
Let me, I feel like there's been no announcements.
So let me, I don't, I haven't been tagged in anything.
So let me look at that server, because I realized, wait, that's a little, that's a little concerning that I haven't heard anything about.
Okay.
okay they're still prepping it okay it seems like no announcement has been up yet so wait did i wait a minute okay oh oh fuck that was last year i was like wait a minute did they start or it i was like okay no i'm looking at last years no i i'm a hider um um wait where's this fuck i'm looking at last year's server okay this is this year's server okay at everyone okay all right let me read this at everyone real quick um information uh okay so there hasn't really been any there has oh no i'm a seeker by the way not a hider i'm a seeker sorry i forgot how hide how to play hide and seek but i'm here to find people okay so they haven't publicly said anything but it is this week i i hope it's still this week but it is this saturday so so i'm just i'm just hoping that like you know everything is still but if there isn't a hot and sea tournament um on saturday then it's a free day for me yay because yeah so the schedule it looks like it's gonna be a lot of street fighter i don't know if i can
fit anything else um because i feel really bad that I have not practiced street fighter.
I'm not touched street fighter yet.
We might touch a little bit here.
Like I said, I don't know what to play.
I don't know, guys.
I don't know.
Because I feel like if I did get coaching for Honda when I start my coaching session on Honda, maybe I'll be like a fucking god.
Because it's one button, you know, like maybe I'll be like, because like, you know, I didn't know how to play Zangiv until I got coached on how to play Zangiv.
So I'm just like thinking, like, I remember I didn't really like Honda at first because I didn't really know how to play him.
And like Zangief, I literally was just abusing the grapple.
But like for Honda, I felt like, I feel like, oh, I need to get coached to see, to actually like know if I, if I do want to play, if I do want to play, uh, play him.
So, so it's, I'm in a really tough, because if I, if I play Zangief, I can literally like try to do him right now because like, I feel like it'll come back to me.
As long as I remember which button was to grab, I feel like...
The moment I remember how to grab someone, it all comes back to me.
But I don't know.
I don't know about Honda.
Because I've never actually played them before.
Yeah, and then people...
The thing is, they nerfed the damage.
They nerfed the damage for Xankeep.
So I don't know.
my loyal fans?
I don't know.
Or do I do something new?
Because at that point, I might as well like, I'm actually, like, a new player at that point.
But yeah, so we'll figure this out.
We'll figure it.
Maybe we'll fucking try a little bit of Street Fighter there today.
Like I said, I don't run around, but anyway, let's play some Rankeroonies.
I don't know how much I'm gonna, I don't know how much I'm going to play ranked today.
At this point, I'm just doing it just so because I needed to pad my...
Well, I already have 100 hours, but I want the people to look at my channel and be like, did we get rated?
I don't want them to be like, did we get rated?
Or someone like bot nominated me.
So I was like, oh, no, she actually does stream rivals.
Salvia, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
And I don't want to do too much because then it would feel like, you know, it would feel like, you know, it would feel like a chore instead of me actually wanting to play rank.
So I'm just going to play rank until I don't feel like it anymore, which could be like two hours.
It could be six hours.
Who knows?
I do have a stream today as well.
So who the fuck knows how I feel?
No, I just feel like, you know, it looks wrong.
obviously someone who does stream rivals every single day um and then they look at me like but i have passion for rivals i have a lot of passion for the game it's just that you know i have to also sort of be a variety streamer like like the rivals is just a bonus like a hobby like streaming is my job and marble rivals is my hobby like oh my god mega thank you for really appreciate it Thank you so much.
Oh my god.
It really means a lot, man.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted subs.
Also, Wafi, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Um, so yeah, like, um, I'm not watching this shit.
He's like, have some money.
Fuck Rivals.
Uh, T, thank you for the tier, we're gifting a tier one sub.
Thank you.
Let's say, at least thank you for stopping.
I do appreciate the support.
He did, like, a one and done.
I'm paying and leaving.
He just, like, went to the restaurant, paid for his water, and then left.
What a sin today.
All right.
It's time.
I felt so inspired today.
If you guys watch today's stream, you know I feel extra inspired today at Buckley.
Club Dokeybird.
When you support your Oshi, but low-key, don't fuck with the game.
All right, guys.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Club Dokeybird.
Do we have any customers?
Oh, come on, guys.
Yeah.
Come on, we know you want to dance.
Come on, girl.
Come on, Peter.
Who's getting...
You gotta pay New York rent, Peter.
Oh, you know, I'll give you guys an example.
Guys, all you have to do is go up here and be like, yeah!
Whoa, what the fuck, bro?
You think Poles are cheap?
Poles are not cheap in this economy.
Bro, especially Poles that are, like, resistant to...
I'm saying Megatron.
Magneto.
You know how hard it is to find metal resistant uh pulls for magneto oh my god that definitely would not be cheap it's very hard to find pulls that won't get bent by magneto when he comes in uh he is a very loyal customer yeah mega tron no they both started with m and they're practically the same person If you think about it All right,
come on spider-man come on.
I know you're a freak.
Come on Come on, come on, wait, no, no, here.
Let me show you let me show you I'll teach you guys So you go to this and you just start whoa You just start dancing.
Yeah, that's right.
You guys got it, right?
Come on.
Don't worry.
We'll teach you Put dancing one-on-one 101 there you go.
Okay, so you see this you do that and then you go whoa that's right you can do it too you see that flip that's your turn oh my god oh my god that's gonna come out of your paycheck like i can't believe it these people it's it's four in the morning if anything if anything these are these are like the club joekeeper like patrons these are the people who are going to strip clubs like who goes to a strip club in the morning it's still prime time it's prime time dance hours all right here you go here you go look the pennies got guys the sore losers got fistful thank you for the uh gifting a tier one sub thank you thank you i feel like anyone that goes to a club in the morning that's just so sad like like like are there even any strip Who takes the morning shift for like...
Who the fuck takes the morning shift for like a club?
They just want a party, man.
And not providing the entertainment!
Oh my god, it's been six minutes.
I'm Celestial too, it's not even that high of a rank.
Like...
Are you fucking kidding me?
Where the fuck are my players?
enjoy the yeah the doom cures don't have time to role play that's so sad we should all have time to rp it's all we have that end losing elo there's actually a lot of finance works who sometimes work late and tip like why do you have so much knowledge about like how much people tip in the in the stripping industry huh how come you know don't act no i'm gonna ask i'm gonna this is a this is an interview with mr foxblade or mrs foxblade how do you how do you know so much please feel free enlighten me oh you're so lucky i found a game i have very fun friends are you i have three gm players Are you fucking kidding me?
And I have someone who got into the grand finals.
Like...
Do you think you want to be today?
I don't have three GM players.
That's it.
It's rocket time.
So we got into the MRC finals and the second in the enemy team.
And I have GM players.
I should get the MRC finalists.
Oh yeah.
I did watch the finals in the semi-finalists.
I did watch the MR, what's it, Ignite, the million dollar Ignite.
Which hell is this?
Do you know everyone that queues at this fucking degenerate hour?
Like, but I did watch a little bit of Ignite and Doom Raid.
That's good side.
And, um, I will say, I mean, other than, like, the dude crying and, like, super passionate um i will say the games were not that exciting because it was just everyone knew that vp was just gonna win and it felt like it was just a hard stomp on one team every game like like for the semi-finals for the quarterfinals for the semi-finals and then the finals it just felt like hard stomp on one side so it just didn't feel like uh um it just didn't it didn't feel like an exciting watch you know because you know exactly which team was gonna win in each matchup like it was obviously you know it was obviously uh uh vp and then navi and it was gonna be vp and navi but vp was gonna win because uh vp was the strongest team overall so it wasn't that exciting I was just like I did watch it but I was just like it just felt super predictable it's more exciting when you know the matches are a lot closer
yeah but then if because it was the last day the thing is it was the last day for the tournament but like you know it was the last day like All the matches there was just a stomp for one team like it none of the matches were close like none of the matchups Is there like four four one four one four one or four zero four one four one
I don't know my team was so bad.
It was actually so sad What?
I don't even know what you're saying I don't know that's just how this game is I feel like majority players here also EU at this time because right now because it didn't because it's a regular time for them oh no not a sidewalk stranger danger I hope you're gonna help this help him hello hello we're gonna say hello here too hey guys there is a lot of people here there's a rebuy beacon back there though yeah whoa hey guys there's a hell of behind us I should have said something but like fuck them I guess though I'm doing something very hard right now and that is this holy shit please tell me I live oh my god oh my god okay nice Guys,
look at that, guys.
Did you see that?
I use the corner.
I learned.
I don't put it out in the open anymore, guys.
Guys, I figured out how to play Rocket.
It's crazy.
One of my healers as well.
It's crazy, guys.
I figured it out.
Improvement.
Oh my god.
I figured it out.
What the fuck how did he get here?
What oh my god.
He never left.
He never fucking left.
I was like, where was he?
There's an interesting play from him Don't worry guys.
I'm not going in there.
I never I don't trust stacking anymore I saw what happened in ignite guys I saw what happened SILOC is so fucking broken it's like whichever team literally has the better SILOC there it's so dumb yeah I don't trust oh my god that's crazy I don't even know how he did it how the fuck did he do that wait how actually how the fuck
That's unfortunate.
Like, I don't even know how he killed all those people.
Wait, where's my... Okay, maybe I should...
I don't want...
There you go.
What?
Oh, shit.
Wait, who destroyed it?
I don't even know who the fuck destroyed it.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, oh, unless he wasn't looking... Oh, never mind.
He's...
still dead.
Oh, and then they have a Moon Knight?
I don't even know when that happened.
Goodbye.
I leave now.
I still don't know how we got three kills off of the fucking Namor.
I know some of you guys were like, why Rock it?
Life's been really hard on the supports.
I don't I don't even Life has been very hard for support players I have to play I have to play Rocket What the fuck?
I don't even know how Look I'm doing my best here I think I'll be fine right
Where the Oh, there's no way we're not.
No, bro.
I can't up this.
There's Namor, though.
There's only two of us.
I actually will so hard on the Namor.
I'm so confused.
It was just like me and my strange.
So I was like, I can't help this.
I'll have to help the next fight.
All right, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I know how to use high ground.
Don't worry, guys.
Okay.
Okay, it's gone.
I don't know what happened.
I have a little word.
Oh shit.
That's fine.
We have ult.
That's right.
That's what my ult was for.
I knew he was gonna name her that.
So I used that to save us.
And it worked.
We were saved.
Oh my god.
I have to reload though.
Okay, I can't save that.
I don't know.
Do I play a different healer?
Like, I don't think I'm the problem.
I don't think...
I mean, I could...
I guess I will.
Oh, no, I vault again.
Wait, I vaulted again.
Let's go.
I'm not the problem.
I think I should play maybe Invis.
Because I can get enough...
They do have name more.
Actually, I don't know.
Oh, right, let's...
Hmm...
Do I go a real healing?
So high.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, there's a...
Hella right behind us.
We're just letting this one guy thank us.
He's still behind us!
Bro!
I don't know if we make it.
Wait, I thought we were going to cloak up.
Gotta block me.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Portal up.
Oh, shit.
That's not unlucky anymore.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
No point.
Oh, my God.
Here we go.
Just in case.
For this one gat.
Oh Okay, it's fine I can't kill her.
I'm fucking one the raccoon How do I kill do you see the damage on this fucking gun?
Selfiest hello, like I literally do like p damage to this gat You're doing what?
I'm like, I'm just one little raccoon in a big, scary world.
Oh my god, we finally went back, Mito.
Finally.
Oh my god.
We're good.
That's unlucky that our strange had to die like that.
I mean, I could still go a real character.
But like, oh, okay, I mean, that's my sign.
I guess that's that's the universe telling me I should swap but I mean they're not going dive so it's fine that's the thing I can play this just because they're not going dive
Jesus Chris you got like every heal in the fucking world for that
okay guys there is still like these guys i don't even know is any of my team technically flanking oh my god that should have hit that should have been oh thank god no
i'm so sad i'm so sad i literally needed like one no no okay I was gonna see okay we just gotta live no I need him I need him one hit like one hit from my cloak and I would live that's all I needed I was literally I got hit by the fucking onk all right fine fine I'll go Luna no I haven't tried this back yet I want to but the last the last two weeks I've been like hell for me.
They're going to get rid of the command for Luna.
Because they're flanking a lot.
They're just shooting from behind.
I mean, he's right.
They are.
Literally, I'm just getting a shot in the back.
A week and a half for the final episodes.
I'll just wait for the final episode.
I like playing everything at once.
I don't like wait.
I don't like...
I personally hate episodic shit.
I don't...
Because it's like, I forget what happens.
Who is our flanker?
Does our name our flanker or is our hella flanker?
Fine, I guess I'll play Luna Because they're not going I only go to rocket when they're dive and they usually dive I guess at this time people don't know how to play dive
Oh my god Eelom, thank you again Oh, thank you, El Omega Thank you again for the subs Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
See, I know you couldn't escape Marvel Rivals.
I know you'd come back.
I knew it.
No one truly escapes Marvel Rivals.
Jesus Christ.
The only scary part about this is that I have to be like so careful with my positioning too because as rocket i can oh my like i i don't know what you want me to do i literally you're getting so much healing right now holy fuck oh my god there's just too much damage well thank you for gifting us up to mega thank you thank you bro there It was just so much damage.
There was nothing I could do.
All I did was heal.
They were not healthy, guys.
They were absolutely not healthy.
I'm going to rock it over here.
Get predicted.
But also, I did it to save my own life.
It was technically not a prediction.
I saw myself low HP.
And I was like, I got to save my ass.
Get predicted!
That was a really bad Invisal.
Who the fuck did I kill?
I missed my heal and I shot someone.
Like, I'll take it.
Are you serious?
I like how I missed my shot and I got a kill out of it.
Yeah, I know
The thing is they're they don't even have oh my we just let the hell just
I died because hell was above and I painted like like a minute ago.
Yeah, I don't know my hell is not doing anything about it Whoa I'm shooting my first.
She's gonna get killed.
I was over here.
Oh Clearly you're not doing enough.
Oh, I'm frozen.
Oh my god, we did it.
We killed him.
I'll give it to our Namor.
I think our Namor deserves it more.
He got the kill, so he gets the reward.
He gets the good boy, the good boy flake.
To be fair, our Namor is the one that's doing the most stuff.
What?
We need healing.
I'll paint it, I'll paint it.
Oh no.
Oh no, guys.
You got him.
I think it's happening.
They're all hell out of nowhere.
I gotta whisper it now.
I think I might have gotten neighbors.
Oh, where is he?
Oh shit.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
Get shit on.
I have my neighbors very angry right now inside my door.
Good grief, Luna.
Luna on the side.
Oh no, I can't just leave.
I'm in a game.
Just so easy.
I'll leave the moment this game.
is over but i can't leave i'm like one no no why am i still alive oh he is so proud now what oh no oh no i'm so distracted wait i keep that okay okay
okay this is bad guys i don't think i could do late night streams anymore i think i actually got new neighbors and they do not like it
oh my god there is a mag all i'm alive though
oh no i think i got new neighbors because I've never had complaints before I think no one no one lived next to me for so long and finally someone lives next to me now I because I've never had a complaint before what all this to our left here oh this is bad he's caught they're causing like a little
They knock my door.
They knock my door and then let...
This is not good.
What?
Actually, no, I can.
They don't have support for now.
I have to soundproof my room now.
I'm so sad.
I've never had a single noise complaint before.
So I thought it'd be fine.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
please i would alone on cart okay i can't bro you were getting body blocked what do you want me to do i'm trying oh i couldn't i couldn't
bro i can't fucking i'm so i'm so tilted i can't believe I have oh my god our hell has 17 kills oh my god it's for it's like um it's 510 but I've never had um I've never had a noise complaint before I don't think it was I don't think it was me though but because like look at our name or our name or did so much he has like um so they have like 31 final hits but no this is sad this is actually sad okay give me a sec i have to oh yeah no they complain for 10 in the morning and then like i had a late night stream before so like i never had complaints before so like this is i think i got new neighbors because like um you know i've done loud streams before and especially like during the afternoon so i mean it doesn't help that my streaming room is like closer to the door outside so so it really sucks and um oh that sucks ah that really sucks and i actually have to soundproof my apartment my apartment i don't know how to soundproof i gotta look up a youtube tutorial yeah but they knock on my
door and then they set off my dog who like you know obviously he's not happy
oh my god the thing is my walls don't do well with the foam shit because it keeps falling so like I need to figure out how to I don't know because they complain at 10 30 a.m like like that's not even that early and they complain at like 10 30 a.m.
and stuff and I was like bro it's 10 30 a.m.
and like I didn't want to and I was trying to teach to like not be such a fucking brat um because like I can't like listen to him every time like I'm I can't like um you know obviously like I can't like always listen give him what he wants every time he's barking but now I have to so he's like extra spoiled because I'm so worried about noise complaints now um I'm I'm so worried about noise complaints these days because ever since that 10 30 a.m incident happened um so like i have to give him what he wants um i have to give him what he wants every time he barks at me so i like so he knows now he he knows that uh um he knows that like you know i'm like i'm weak willed like it's under sound like i know he's complained at this hour but i've never had a complaint before i've never had a complaint before And I've been living here for like almost two years.
Oh, not even a year.
It's like a year and a half.
I've been here for a year and a half.
I've done D-Gen hours and I've never had a complaint before at this time.
And I swear to God, I've been so loud.
I've been so loud before.
I didn't realize how, yeah, I didn't realize how loud.
If I fucking hear them knocking on my door, the thing is i'm also like in the game so i can't take the i can't leave because i don't want to get reported so i guess i gotta i gotta figure out how to sound proof because like if they start complaining during my regular hours then it's a problem i understand if it's like at this time i understand because like i said it's five in the morning so like that sense you know like maybe they were sleeping and then i was i'm too loud i feel like yeah not getting reported by me that's true not getting reported in game um no it has to be an it has to be a noise complaint because like they've never i've never got someone knocking on my door outside before other than for like um also fool thank you for the raid thank you thank you we're just dealing with a noise complaint i'm it's like when when super had to like when super got um kicked out because he was too he got new neighbors he got new neighbors and then apparently he also got kicked out of his
apartment um because they filed a noise complaint against yeah yeah like he had to find like a house or something to live in um because like uh because his he got new neighbors as well and then they also he got kicked out yeah
also see they give her gifting a tier one so it's a noisy ridiculous thank you i'm gonna also the thing is my door's not locked so i'm gonna go lock my door in case they barge
my door's not locked they were like knocking on my door i didn't know my door's not locked
I guess I'm like, no one's going to come into my apartment.
Like, okay, give me a sec.
I got to start locking my door, guys.
Okay.
Adu.
I wonder what we're going to do.
I'm too trusting.
Adu.
There's no one outside my, there's no one outside my, my apartment right now.
i'm so sad i'm so sad i love playing dgen fuse too they're my favorite type of fuse because you can encounter you can encounter so many wild okay i need actually i need to avoid the the hella that was that was uninspiring i'm sorry but that was that was such an uninspiring game from our hella it was it was so sad so i i got avoid him i don't i can't believe it i'm so dead i forgot to soundproof this room this is why i wanted to move too because my my streaming room is like too close to the door i think if like i think if my room was uh uh no i'm pretty sure it's like it's basically because i'm too loud like like they weren't because dad wasn't barking he wasn't barking um until they started knocking on the door that's when he started barking because obviously he's like what the fuck is that you know he's like what is that like who's that outside the door um but it's definitely because I was too loud but like i never realized um i never realized that uh no i'm not assuming because they
were literally knocking on my door in the middle of my like while i was streaming and and dad wasn't barking he wasn't barking until they knocked like three times and it was like super loud knocking i don't know if you guys heard the knocking but it was like really loud knocking and then dad started freaking out because he was like um he was like what the was that like like why why is he letting them knock on her door um yeah and it's like if they can hear me um if they can hear me like from my streaming room in their apartment then i just need a sound like what else can i do i can all i could do is just soundproof my room you know like if i talk to them they're just gonna be Like,
what's that going to solve?
Like, I'll be like, oh, sorry.
Let me, like, I can't be like, sorry, I'm a streamer.
Also, I don't want to tell them that, like, I'm a streamer.
This is my job, you know?
I don't have to, no.
It's a logical, like, at that point, they might even put up more complaints.
Because they're like, oh, like, you know.
They'll, like, be like, you can only stream at least hours or some shit.
And I don't want my neighbors to control, like, what time I stream.
Yeah, because they'll be like, oh, you streamed, like, you stream, like, outside of your scheduled hours.
I rather just get the soundproofing in, and then they'll never have to, like, if I, they'll never have to, no.
Yeah, but why else would I be fucking shouting at five in the, it's, like, literally my job.
They're like, just stop.
If I be like, oh, I'm just playing video games.
Like, don't play video games at this time, you know?
They'll just say that, shit like that.
you have to buy a house um bro houses here are so expensive i'll just soundproof the place i might i might like i'll look into like like in the end like the logical conclusion in the end is only sure what the like wait why are you oh wait you're always in a dgen time never mind Do you see here that Gully wants to bring back the old Fortnite crew sure for?
And then we were watching the Ice Spice clip.
He wants to bring back the squad.
What do you mean?
Did you not see the new update?
The new Simpsons update, bro?
For those who've never seen the clip, let me show you guys.
sent we were like reminiscing about fortnight how can you say fortnight sucks when we had this magical clip together I love
I love the title she a baddie this is such a good clip I love this clip so much all
right maybe the game won't be as bad now.
How much have you spent on Fortnite?
Who's keeping count?
Who even is aware?
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Who keeps track of how much money people spend on gotcha, huh?
If I don't judge you for your gotcha, you don't judge me for Fortnite.
Okay, I need to give him a tree.
Alright, give me a second.
Oh, shit.
Alright, my slipper got caught on the head go fire.
Round one!
Even when the multiverse is in danger, family still comes first.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
I hate when that happens.
I always, like, drop my headphones.
Oh, my sweet Susan Storm.
It's Richard's name.
As you are...
well aware all right oh my god okay okay this is not inspiring uh hulk hulk okay this is absolutely not inspiring hulk hulk solo take and mantis okay mantis with me as okay that's cool oh you know no we gotta kill we gotta kill i'm so inspired now you know what never judge a book by it's covered You know what they always say?
This is like still not lit.
Jesus Christ.
This is so hard to heal.
Why are you trying, please?
I'm so sad because...
Bro, I almost... I was gonna pull the penny down and then he fucking stuns him.
Ah yes, the flank... the front.
Lion Widow.
Yeah, this might not be enough, yes.
This absolutely is not enough, yes.
Okay, I was gonna say I better kill him.
I should not be playing Invis with this comp.
I don't have enough, like, bodies to charge my... Oh!
Did they dodge?
Oh, somebody dodged.
Thank god.
God.
Thank fucking God.
Fuck my team.
I'm happy.
I'm glad they're gone.
I didn't close my door, though.
I'm safe.
Someone was like, I am playing this game at five in the morning.
And rightfully so.
Rightfully so.
I don't think anyone wants to play that game at five in the
Yeah, I'm in a soundproofing Take I most likely will hire someone I do not trust myself You guys are ready If you guys watched my first Today's stream If you guys watched today's stream You guys can tell already Or like yesterday's stream How bad my DIY Project was Or DIY
My DIY project was So bad I definitely need to hire someone.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'll show you guys.
For those who didn't watch the sponsor stream, because, you know, you're like, oh, it's sponsored.
Like, it's sponsored.
But basically, I'll show you guys the picture.
So, long story short, I was trying to get a base station from a...
VR or VR set up and I didn't have a mount to do it yeah no it's tape it's tape so I forgot to order a mount to place my face station which is like the little square thing that people use to do VR tracking and stuff for your VR headset so but it has to be on the wall and my brilliant idea use foam,
my audio foam, but you see this up top above here, you see the thing on top here, um, the thing at the top right here, that's a vent.
And what I didn't know is that, you know, silly me, um, hot air melts.
So this is what's supposed to, this is what my plan was to put the, to use audio foam because it, because you need to.
And I, it works on the other side and still holding up, by the way, the other side, um, I put an audio phone on there.
and I put the base station up top on top of it because I was like okay I didn't buy a mount this is like my next brilliant idea so um obviously I figured it should work on the other side too yes it's it's gorilla tape it's gorilla tape so it's very strong tape so what I didn't realize is that hot air melts tape melts the sticky the adhesive for tape so when I put the foam there and I put the base station on top of it,
it fell like three times.
And I was like, what do I do?
And I was like panicking because I had my sponsor.
Like, what do I do?
So what I did instead
was what I did was I grabbed a microphone box that I still kept and I smashed it against the wall and it worked.
box over audio foam um and and that is why yeah see this is my do it yourself DIY so this I like I said I don't trust myself on DIY projects um because this is what's my solution on on how to how to mount because I forgot to buy I forgot to buy the wall mounts So I don't know if it's cheaper
There's nothing to do with being good at streaming It's just I was MacGyvering that shit though It worked It worked though It's unrelated to streaming it was a bonus I mean we're gonna do hammer crossing I'm gonna do an hammer cross fuck it I'll keep playing Luna yeah I'm thinking outside of the box with a box um but yeah um so with that that's why I should hire someone to do the soundproof thing because I don't know like that took me by the it.
Doing all of that took me three hours.
There was a lot of trial and error.
It was no, you know, there was a lot of trial and error.
Before we before I fell into the conclusion that box is the answer.
It took me three hours to be like ah yes a box it took three hours to tape a box to go up
you'll need a top-notch team to win this one i'm gonna snow put this on our captain america
i don't feel very inspired right now i think i like oh we don't have the silo yeah three hours and also lots of crying you're right there was that too
Yeah, after it fell twice, the foam, I was like, let me try it one more time.
Yeah, but the thing is, if I build a soundproof roof, it's gonna be even hotter in this room.
And I don't fucking want to deal with that.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
This sucks.
Fucking new neighbors.
i'm sad i'm so sad we got i'm so sad we got new neighbors my old neighbors were so chill they let me they let me scream at my screen for 12 hours straight playing marvel rivals how dare they need a sleep if my neighbors are listening to now that that's a joke i didn't mean that i was just trying to make the ha ha funny to my chat i did not mean that i swear like i swear oh my god that's very unfortunate that we got double hooked
that's so unlucky oh my that was such a good hook too
i missed my non-confront confrontional confrontional oh my confrontinal non-confrontional no that's not how you say it you just didn't like confronting me if they were old neighbors and they just let me be i miss them i forced them to move out but at least non-confrontational non-confrontational yes yes
where's our captain america oh there he is i was gonna say i need to give him oh my god he lives he doesn't live though Oh, holy shit.
Okay, that guy is insane.
I don't know if you guys saw, but he is...
He's actually...
Oh my god, he got four.
The shark got four.
Yeah, we...
This team is not...
Yeah, oh my god.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
Yeah, pumpkin.
Yeah, he's the Halloween skin.
Oh, now we have Angela.
Yesterday, last stream, I won every game.
This stream, it's not doing so well.
I'm getting actual...
I was supposed to be the EOMM agent.
I don't understand.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, I was gonna say, you need it all at first.
It should not be me.
Okay, I guess I do the damage.
Hello, Angela.
I'm a little scared, Angela.
Alright, here you go.
I do have up, so...
I gotta make sure I don't get grabbed.
Aw!
That's unlucky.
Oh!
Hey, guys, there is one little boy here.
I don't think I should have used my up there.
I got a little scared.
Oh yeah, no, I definitely fucked up by using a...
Because he still has...
Oh, nice.
Unless I didn't fuck up.
Oh.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Did he use that to escape, bro?
You know, he tried to get a clip.
That's understandable, you know?
He tried to get a clip.
Oh my god, I swear to god.
Oh my...
The EOMM Give us and the EOMM Take it.
Oh, it was just Bucky.
Nothing to worry about.
Just our little Bucky, boy.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he literally kidnapped uh, kidnapped or bucky just for him to get a 3k that's sad okay we have all for strange thank you i feel like myself again now he's doing it for widow because our widow will actually be non-existent if it wasn't for a mantis like like you might think he's non-existent now but like he could have been like even worse i know it's crazy that's like possible oh they still have
The only way I know how, because we can't take any damage.
Oh, I gotta move back.
Is that strange?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Oh my.
Okay, I legitimately thought he was gonna...
Okay, I thought he was gonna...
Honestly, if the Strange Ulti 3, it would have been so smart for him.
Oh, I keep forgetting I have only Mantis here.
So I can't, like, front and die.
What if I...
There you go.
I don't know.
I didn't trust him.
It's sort of hard to...
To trust people in this Elo, you know?
Oh, there it is.
Goodbye.
I will say, I wasn't gonna live regardless.
If I had a...
Because, like, we had GM players, so I don't trust them to...
I don't trust them to counter Jeff.
It's very hard to trust GM players to throw a rock on a Jeff.
Also, like, trusting people in matchmaking is, like, not it.
God, I feel so nerfed.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he did more stuff without...
That's actually crazy.
He was more useful without a fucking mantis.
Oh.
That's bad.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, that's very bad.
Bro.
I I don't know.
I'm I'm trying here.
Oh
Why why did you throw?
He actually threw He threw me He fed me The terror store is One two zero He actually Spend me Including which side you're That's crazy.
Who are you calling a raccoon, huh?
The right heroes could make all the difference.
He threw three of us.
He ate all three.
I told you guys, this is why I don't trust my teammate.
This is why I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I told you.
I fucking told you.
I can't trust me.
I can't trust Gia.
players.
I don't think he understood that he chucked all of us into the enemy team.
He was like, really only one I could eat.
But he doesn't understand that he, he chucked.
You're just mad that you're... He's so stupid.
He's actually special.
He's so stupid.
Didn't ask.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, this is dead.
Come on, no.
Oh, I hate it.
I hate it.
I have to be so careful.
Now it's not like that.
I think I prefer him on Mantis.
I, yeah, no, I definitely prefer my, I prefer him on Mantis.
we're running triple there you go that should help there you go okay we're on triple tank now it should work right but are they on triple oh they're on triple they were on triple I didn't even notice that guys I think we should leave guys guys guys why the fuck should we all push up
Yes, I think Emma doesn't have mobility.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And who was it that did the push?
Like, Jeff, you were not doing anything.
What the fuck do you mean to sit?
What did you provide in that fight?
I have no idea if my team is saved or not.
There you go.
Oh, yummy, yummy.
Oh, okay.
Okay, Jeff.
We are down three.
How did he know?
Oh my, no, our Jeff is special.
Our Jeff is like, our Jeff is so special.
He doesn't know how to place Jeff.
Like, I can't defend this.
Where's our Jeff, by the way?
Oh, there it is.
I'm like...
It's fine, I pushed him away.
Okay, but who's gonna help me though?
There we go.
I just... what?
Okay, same guy.
Thank God.
Okay, he's fine.
I mean, we didn't start them.
There we go.
Holy fuck.
No, this Jeff is my EOMM agent.
No, 100%.
I don't even know how we're alive.
They have two fights.
God, I hate Triple T, though.
Oh, at least we're...
Oh, wait.
They got off Triple T.
Nice.
I feel so nerfed knowing that I have to be who would have thought you got to be quiet at five in the morning
I don't know where he's gonna be oh this is bad
really okay well I hope he does a good eat okay
He was not...
He...
He did not do a good eat.
He really...
Yeah...
Yeah, maybe... Yeah.
and really you know our team wins die yeah he took way too long oh god i have to
jesus christ oh i missed okay sad he missed you jesus christ oh goodbye oh that was such a good stranger Why can't R-Strange do that?
It's not fair.
Why can't R-Strange be good like that?
Also, why can't we have that death too?
Hey, that guy knows what he's doing
All right
God, I'm trying so hard soldier.
I'm trying so hard america Yeah
Maybe I can use it to... Oh, I don't need to engage.
Yeah.
I was gonna say I could use my other tent.
Oh!
Never mind.
America!
I'm like, Cleo, thank you so much for the raid!
Wait, have you been streaming this entire time?
Since the...
Since the sponsor?
Mr. Cleo, thank you for the raid?
I have to be really quiet because I got a noise complaint.
Because for some reason, people don't like it when you're loud at 5.
in the morning so but thank you I really appreciate it try my best try my best and not be too loud oh god you live are you serious we had we had two shields where was the other shield oh my god what was our shield what was our shield What happened?
We have two tanks in it that has a fucking shield.
One is diamond and the other one is a actual shield in war.
It's made of Vibranium.
That's okay.
It's not okay, but that's okay.
We just had too many tank players apparently.
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
I heard that portal and I knew.
I hate it.
Oh, I hate it.
It was a silent portal too.
Wait, what?
Two two one
Oh, it was right there.
I didn't even realize Yeah, no their strange is just so wait did we win?
Yay
Yay!
Wait, I won?
We did not deserve that.
We 100% did not deserve that one.
Yay!
This is Celestio slash TM.
A tier below, one below eternity.
No.
Oh my god.
Trying to make sure you don't.
to give me another noise complaint i how did it happen how did it happen what's worse me on angela or my lord bro bro there your jeff was so good aren't we had like okay i'm gonna avoid him okay wait i need to know how the did we win that did he not see what my jeff did what the does he mean like there i wish i had this jeff i get 17 for that that's how low it was like i had yeah i was literally oh my god i was literally the highest ring player on my team oh my god it feels so sad yeah i need the replay i need to know what the fuck was going on
okay i need to remember how to use the camp Alright, so that's the point.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh yeah, no, they all went.
Oh yeah, no, it was...
Okay, yep.
They all ran.
Okay, so that's what happened.
There's the point.
Alright.
Oh yeah, and like two of them are here and The other three are in the pro.
It was two people.
Only two of us were alive.
I was like, what?
I thought the point, like, I was like, wasn't the point over here?
How did we lose?
Because obviously, we all know my team was the worst team.
So I was like, I was like, wait, day one?
I thought the point was over there.
And I was right.
What?
That's crazy.
We did not deserve that.
Their team was, they had a better tank, they have a better strange, they had the better Jeff.
Like, they all just walked up.
Yeah, my Jeff was actively helping their team as much as possible.
Like he was, he got the PayPal money and he still won.
All right.
Fuck, I want to play more.
I'm so sad.
I want to play more.
The thing is, okay, here's the worst part.
You guys are like, why don't you just get a blanket and put it under your door for soundproofing?
But I can't because I have a sliding door, which is the worst type of door, which is absolutely the worst type of door to soundproof because it's a sliding door.
And it's a glass, like it's a glass.
sliding door and so I if I put a blanket underneath I still have to worry about the other other crevices around my door all right I our Jeff did not deserve MVP there and also who is this strange it was him right toast chat no who the fuck was our strange this guy was always Captain America right yeah no this guy this guy you were not a great strange
all right one more one more i'll do one more if i hear knocking then like i'm blaming you guys not me
tuck it in where i gotta get tape okay there's no way to tuck it it's literally a sliding door on the outside
all right it's not my fault if i get kicked out if i get kicked out i'm sending you the bill for my moving fee
I don't, oh wait, I do, though the closet is not going to fit my streaming setup.
100%.
My setup is too big for a closet.
Technically, this is a closet.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's supposed to be a closet or like a bedroom.
I have no idea.
But I made it into my office.
I didn't even realize I was yelling that loud.
that passionate about my team my team was so bad and it was the first you guys don't understand my first team my first game today was that bad my first game they were not real people
just keep taping soundproofing on the walls until the complaints stop yeah it was so bad that i got my very first noise complaint that wasn't related to my dog
but to be fair um i don't think like i don't know if that was my neighbors knocking or my concierge because like the first time it was my concierge that like knocked the door because like they went to the concierge to tell me i think i fought the con usually concierge doesn't check in until uh he doesn't check in until like later on because it's just a security guys a concierge it's just the person at the lobby that runs the lobby at the front but yeah oh yeah please feel free to um please please please yeah i'm sorry i can't english please feel free to nominate me for best marble rival streamer i am risking my apartment for this nomination with the streamer awards guys i really appreciate it yeah yeah yeah just put the okie bird for best marvel rival streamer no next week okay also like this week i might i'm gonna do the soundproofing next week because i'm like like obviously like um um i was planning on on like uh doing soundproofing anyway uh but like before i had the noise
complaint because like you know dad's been barking a lot lately so i was just thinking of just like um getting that sorted out um and so because this week is super packed right this is super packed so obviously i can't do anything um because like my tires i don't even know if i have rest days at all today uh this week but um sat sunday and monday i might i'm gonna work on like setting everything up or or like hiring a person to uh to do the soundproofing have you just tried no Have you ever tried asking a weaner dog to not bark?
That's like almost impossible.
I think weaner dogs or like doxins are like the one of the most brattiest and stubborn dog breeds out there.
But God, I've owned like three generations of them.
Yeah, they are like one of the most...
They have the second...
Yeah, they're born to be loud.
They have the...
I have...
They have the second loudest barks out of all breeds.
Because they were bred to hunt badgers.
Yeah, he's very stubborn.
It's the fucking...
I go on her.
Like, he knows now.
And the fact that he knows that, like, ever since I got my first noise complaint at 10.30 a.m., um, he fucking knows that, like, he runs the apartment now.
I guess before I would just let him bark.
I would just let him bark and be like, no.
Like, go do your thing.
Like, I don't care.
Like, you ain't getting food early.
that like I'm worried about getting kicked out he's like he's like you play by my rules now it's yeah he owns he's the man of the apartment see
I know he is that hello whoa hey guys just want to show whoa yeah he's blackmailing you know he is and he knows it he fucking knows it he is blackmailing me so on sunday and monday most likely no stream uh next week because i gotta figure out the sound proving shit so if i do sound weird on tuesday it's because i'm still getting the shit worked out i sound fucking weird on tuesday
All right, we'll do one more game.
We'll swap to Street Fighter.
I would, I would love to play more.
I actually feeling, I'm feeling, I'm feeling so rivals right now.
I really am.
I'm getting my rivals itch.
This might mean I have to stream rivals at like less of a D-Gen hour.
I might have to, I might have to stream rivals maybe at like 9 p.m.
or 10 p.m.
something the horror I know right I can't believe it what is the tournament it's on Saturday or sorry Friday sorry that's the apex one Friday is the right the Street Fighter tournament Saturday is the apex tournament there's
no way he's a one trick, Hela player.
Hela's getting banned most of the games.
How is that one trick?
In the game lobby.
There's no way.
He's like, what else is he gonna play?
See?
Yeah.
Guys, guys, I'm the one trick.
We banned our own one trick.
How are you one trick, man?
I'm Hela.
Oh, I'm Hela.
I'm one trick, guys.
I'm Hela.
Bro, Hela is banned most of the games.
How you are a one trick?
is uh one above all you never get to play who is who the fuck is he talking about
how did he get to this elo being a one trick hella he got to his eel because he's a one trick hell of playing 30
seconds before you attack to be fair there's like different combination of bands hella's not always mandatory bad because there's daredevil but there's not a lot of people good at daredevil because he's so hard to play but there's you say what oh The Brandon.
You're going to have a fucking field day.
Just get Brandon through two, three, three, three.
That guy is so bad.
Um, but there's, um, there's Daredevil, Lucky, uh, Sala, uh, Emma, Angela, depending on the map.
Like, Venom, like, it's not just, like, it's not, oh, it's not just, hey, yeah.
There we go.
It's animal crossing time.
Hey, buddy.
You might need a play Jeff.
Wait, we live?
I don't even, thank God I went raccoon.
See, this is why I've stopped playing other carry supports.
That is not fun that up if i was you saw that invis do you think that invis was having fun i don't think so no that invis looked like she was having a very miserable time someone have to deal with his father and captain maybe i'm gonna deal with the heater oh my god where is my invis oh wait she's dead they're done with this I'll patch you up.
Yeah, it is.
Um, there is like a guy beating us up.
Can't even put out a res.
Like, where the fuck do I put out the res?
Not gonna, oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's, that's very awkward.
I feel they're really bad.
I feel like we just have to run an animal crossing.
Yeah, man.
Not like, yo.
Yeah.
Oh, I forgot about this guy.
It's okay, we wait, made it.
It's okay, you wasted...
You wasted Phoenix out, guys.
Look at that.
My old was actually pretty badly positioned.
What?
No, what?
It's okay, guys, look at that.
It was planned.
What the fuck?
I wanted him to use the phoenix up.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Bro, what are we doing there?
What?
Let me try my best to keep you up.
Oh, so again.
Bye.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm alive.
Oh my god, I'm barely alive.
Goodbye!
I wanted the extra shield.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh wait, he sees my shield.
I don't know how the fuck we live, but I'll take it.
Oh?
Sure.
Okay, never mind.
is all I can do.
I don't know what I can do for this world.
I'm out here now in Hargorn.
Oh yeah, no.
The Spider-Man definitely has a lot, by the way.
Oh, nice.
Yeah?
Watch this.
Oh, I don't need to use it.
JK.
Don't watch it.
Oh, watch this.
Watch this.
I got scared.
yeah i should look in no that's okay dude take your time it's okay i just have to secure it you know i oh i used it to save myself i may or may not have i may or may not have used it to save my own ass but it worked we got the point oh maybe maybe his job oh hello sorry oh that's okay Okay,
I have a raise.
See, you're back.
Like, you never died.
See, I could have been that poor guy right there.
You got that poor Brandon guy.
You see that?
That could have been me.
That could have been me, guys.
But look at me.
I'm chilling now.
But look at that.
I'll get to chill.
Why can't I reach Celestia playing?
this because you're clearly not playing like this
all it takes a lot of skill to play this bit of a raccoon player it takes a lot of work guys to right click this it takes so much work oh
Jerry's dead.
Look, I was getting Dive, okay?
He literally, he soloed to me.
He was so scared of me.
Guys, he was so fucking scared.
I don't know if you saw that, but he was so scared of me.
He had to solo up me.
That's so sad.
That's how- That's how scared he was.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, is everyone okay over here?
Oh, wait, who?
There he is.
Oh, oh, nice.
Oh, nice, nice.
I get...
Oh, my God.
In my wrist, Liz?
I don't think they look down once.
Let's kill Brandon.
What the fuck did Brandon do to you?
Oh, shit.
They finally got the up.
behind me.
Oh, wait, did I pull it?
Yeah, I pulled it.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh,
yeah.
I died for the cause.
Okay, are they... Okay, I think I have to go over.
I was gonna say, are they not getting it?
Oh, they are.
All right, I gotta do the... I gotta do the walk of shame, guys.
Give me a sec.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
He's gonna find his children, too.
He's gonna terrorize his kids his kids are gonna terrorize his kids i'm going there i'm better what is he this is like generational hate his kids are gonna over his kids too this is like generational oh i'll put it here
The walk got you.
Oh, not her though.
I was talking about her.
I got someone.
It's not this person.
Get rid of him.
Sorry, buddy.
I have to reload.
I live.
Rika, thank you for the Twitch Prime, thank you, thank you.
Bro, bro, bro's about to like get on a list.
This is actually a hate crime at that point.
Bro, is it like...
Oh my god, I need healing, man.
Bro, I haven't stopped right-clicking.
If I could, I'd just bind it on right-click.
Actually...
Okay, oh no, oh no, that's so unlucky.
That's so unlucky.
I forgot, I legitimately forgot if Phoenix was a person, was a character.
Oh, they double-supported all did.
Okay, I will say I forgot that Phoenix even existed because he was that, like, he was that non-existent in this game.
He did not exist for me.
Oh my god, that's okay.
I'm getting out of my arms.
Just stay on the phone.
Oh, please.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Oh, wow.
Uh, Waluuru, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Happy.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Derpy, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yeah, no, I forgot he existed.
Like, the Phoenix had made zero, made like zero impact.
in the game that forgot about her i didn't realize he was real there we go now we do animal crossing
i just throw there by throwing my up when the phoenix tilted but to be fair i feel like if i didn't my team was gonna die because like our star lord star lord was literally like one hp you'll be coming in 30 seconds stay strong
I don't even know what this is.
Okay.
Oh no.
No, stop.
All right.
No.
The battle starts in five.
All right.
Three, three, three, three.
I mean, to be fair, he is getting tired of you carrying Brandon.
You're ready for it.
It's all about Brandon.
There's nothing else.
I saved my fucking Hey, we got we got here.
We got res Hey guys, um Guys, did you at least get Brandon though?
Brandon's dead.
Oh shit.
We did it.
No, no stop.
No, stop.
Guys, we did it.
Operation kill.
Oh, goodbye.
I think we have prob- I think we have- I don't think Brandon's the problem.
Why are we backing up, man?
I think at this point- I think at this point it's not a Brandon issue.
I think we got- guys, guys, I don't know.
This is a wild idea, but what if we focus on other players?
Oh, that's wild, isn't it?
I don't know.
I don't even know what I'm seeing.
But I don't know.
But what if we like, what if other other players exist too?
Isn't that crazy?
You sound like it's only Brandon.
Oh wait,
hello Hello, wait, what?
What the fuck is wrong?
There's no way you fall at this No, no, no, no, no.
I don't want to hear it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What is wrong with me?
He's a very...
That...
No, this guy was fucking terrible.
How did he not kill me?
That's crazy.
I should not have been alive for that long.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm just fucking immortal.
I can't kill him anymore.
Oh, our work condition is gone.
There was no way that I actually lived that long.
That should have been illegal.
the thing is I can't use my because of the fucking because of the spawn man oh my God he's oh he's dead hey there is oh okay guys um
Oh Oh I'm alive
Please please we're both holding our else this Phoenix and I are like fucking playing playing chicken right now The greatest game of chicken of who will up first like
Me and the Phoenix are not holding up We just...
Kill it, kill it, kill it, kill it!
Kill it, kill it, kill it!
We're actually playing the wildest game of chicken.
The old chicken, yeah, who's gonna ult first?
Not me!
Wait, beta looking like I'm taking an ult.
I never wanted to do that.
Not me!
Oh!
I can't ult.
He knows I can't.
I can't hold either.
Oh my god, he knows.
He knows me and that Phoenix playing the wildest.
Oh.
It's time.
Oh, I don't even need to use it.
That's a key, right?
I win all chicken.
I did it.
I won so hard, I never even ulted.
I mean, zero, oh, fuck.
That's right.
I won the chicken.
See, this is why you can't get to Celestial playing the way I do, because you didn't play the way I do.
I was actually playing the...
I kept 16.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That was the wildest raccoon game of mine.
That was, I was not even, like, I didn't stand still for one second.
That's crazy.
Also, Brandon died 16 times.
This guy was not having a good time.
I need to check, I need to check what Brandon was doing.
Bro, I held my ult so good there.
I deserve more.
Alright, Brandon.
Wasn't that low.
There's not a Celestia player.
on right now or how bad was it playing like this guy yeah i want to know how bad why did he not just play raccoon or jeff or jeff like why was he so insistent on playing on playing luna no it's because i was the highest ranked player in the lobby yeah no that's not fun Where the fuck is his other support?
Yeah, no, that's...
See, this is why I stopped playing Luna, guys.
This is...
No, you can...
Now you know why.
I don't...
I don't play Luna anymore.
Because that could have been me.
That could have been me right there.
All I do, I see a Black Panther.
You know what I saw?
I fucking climbed the wall.
Okay, you don't know...
Okay, here's my perception.
perspective.
Okay, that's not very good perspective.
But this is what happened to me when I got dope.
Because I was the enemy team's brand.
Look at that.
I was like, oh, yeah, let me go to my...
Oh, there you go.
This is my pillar now.
Can't kill me.
I got a pillar.
I climb a wall.
That's all you gotta do.
Look at that.
Wall climbed.
Okay, this is crazy.
It broke.
Wall climbed successfully.
Wait a minute.
All right.
I gotta know what does this look like?
That was sad.
All right.
I need to know.
I think he should stop playing DPS.
I think it might be too late for him.
I mean, he got...
He got the panther.
Okay, let's do this.
Bro, stop!
Wait, I need a rewind.
That was...
Wait.
I need a rewind on that.
That was pretty good.
Alright.
Bro, he was...
won and at that time he was committed he was so committed i was just ignoring him and i was still yielding he ain't getting no all here i'm winning all chicken no no no i'm winning all chicken and i did he never altered he only altered one time too that was a good game oh my god i'm feeling it bro okay i'm going um if i get i'll stop until another noise complaint and then and i'll be like i'm sorry i'm risking it all i am holding back so hard guys i'm actually holding back so hard I'm gonna play I'm playing audio chicken now I'm gonna say I am holding back so high right now but I'm still I'm I'm I'm still killing it yet you should notice chick yeah you're to edge the neighbors I'm All right.
There's a mantis.
My first...
My first rookie.
All right.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm gonna find...
We're gonna have some clients tonight.
To be fair, I don't know if 6 a.m.
strip club might not be, like, the most appealing thing.
But where is...
Oh, hey.
Where's the others, man?
Where's...
A mantis.
Mantis!
Mantis.
Do you have dance emu?
I'm here to recruit.
I know where she lives.
Does she?
Does Pete the cat have it?
Dance.
Come on, Pete.
Oh.
I can't believe it.
He doesn't have the money.
You don't matter to me anymore.
She doesn't matter to me anymore.
She's worthless in this business.
I'm not...
I can't make her a star if she doesn't have the dance emote, guys.
That's right.
I'm telling mom, whoa, whoa, hey, I didn't do anything.
I'm telling mom what you did.
That's fucking right.
Womp, womp.
Also, like, if you guys watched the sponsor, I didn't realize that.
But the reason why I was, like, laughing so hard during, you know, the death scene, where, like, like, one of the Nikes died and, like, Bao was like, oh, and then I was just, like, laughing so hard.
It was because I forgot about that because I couldn't hear it.
And it's because Snuffy was like, Womp, Womp.
So obviously I cracked.
Like, I'm fucking crazy.
I'm gonna fucking laugh.
She was like, Womp, Womp.
And Tepsi.
But it was like so quiet that it was barely picked up by the camera.
So I didn't know.
I forgot about it.
Bro, that Nikkei sponsorship was like a home video.
Oh.
because we're like we're doing like a home video oh yeah that's a thick ass pole though you're right i forgot the swap skins like are you can you survive the cringe
it's literally like are you strong enough to to watch this no i feel like i feel like you guys are like the parents watching us vtubers who were the kids at like um at like a school play i was like hello it is i don't keep the bird and then you're like the parents of the camcorder and being like there she is that's my daughter that's my bird
watching the kids do a fortnight dance um in in the christmas play in the Christmas, like, the Bethlehem play, where, like, where, like, he's a three wise man, starts cranking it.
Have you guys ever seen that, what's it called, Scamilton, where, like, a church did a revised version of Hamilton and made it more Christian?
That shit is crazy.
Yeah, it's so fucking funny.
It's so good i'm trying to remember like parts about it but there was like i think there was one part where obviously you know hamilton cheated on his wife with a prostitute but they they couldn't say that like they're like a christian it's like a christian version of a hamilton um so they couldn't i don't remember what they did but they were like we gotta avoid that we can't talk about
oh yeah and then he at the end the past year it was like thank you lynn manuel for approving our copy of like our rewrite of hamilton but then you know someone filmed it i think they didn't realize they i don't know if like originally oh yeah originally it wasn't like you know they weren't expecting it to be like uh published online but someone filmed it and then published it and was
Church did a rewrite of Hamilton.
And then Lin-Manuel sent like a cease and desist to the church and was like, I did not approve of this.
Because the pastor was like, thank you, Lin-Manuel, for giving us approval on letting us rewrite Hamilton to fit more with God.
Yeah, and then, you know, they didn't expect themselves to get fact checked.
So there he was like Please stop I
don't know He actually got sued But like I thought it was funny That he got a cease and desist
Whoa Alright ladies Ladies Stop fighting Oh you know what Yes you also have a lord icon Are we serious I do have a lord icon God, I'm Mantis.
Five out of six.
One guy isn't being a team player.
Look, I don't like that our only DPS is...
Are you actually gonna play Ultron?
He's gonna play Ultron.
Oh my god.
I have not seen Ultron in so long.
Because there's just better triple supports.
This sucks.
I don't, I'm not a fan of, um, our widow being the only DPS, but we get, Tego, we get, uh, I don't see Ultron that much, though.
He's not that, like, because there's better triple support options, you know?
Like, I just don't, I never, I barely ever see Ultron anymore, just because, like, there's other triple supports that are just 100% better.
Like, if anything, he should be going at
triple support and like you should go at them with the mantis so I have like my oh this is bad for him oh this is bad all right this is why this is why I didn't want him didn't want didn't want the widow being our only DPS there What the fuck?
Why do we lock her in?
Oh, that's unlucky.
I feel like us Ultron.
I feel like Ultron's harder to aim than Adam.
I am, um, to have like, um, to have like good damage?
Oh, yeah, no, we should have given Dylan Dubs, like, because he's like an actual Mantis one tray.
Like, he should- he should have been playing.
Manzus.
Can you cue pocket me?
I'm popping all- Oh.
I don't think that's what he meant by pocket.
Hey, guys.
What the fuck happened to my- Okay.
Guys, I don't think when he said, can you pocket me?
I don't think Mantus- It meant, like, Mantus also ulting.
So we lost two support outs in one go and then I got eaten
All right, I don't want to waste this but I don't have to
All right, at least I still have my up haha Yeah, I feel so confident Oh.
The E-O-M-M-Giveth and the E-O-M-M-T take it.
Find you guys.
Oh, let's go.
Alright.
Yeah, no, I would have died.
I would have died if I didn't.
I do not trust this lobby.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, we gotta...
Oh my God, I'm stuck against this lobby.
please swap off ultron please you've got zero kills on ultron i gotta kill over here and i'm luna you know what's the best chance for you to swap off ultron i can't even kill as far as the dvs i can't do he's so nice he's so nice i can't go please please just someone give
Goodbye.
Nope.
That's it.
I'm not enabling this Ultron anymore.
This Ultron can die for all I care.
This Ultron his dad he ain't getting my snowflake he doesn't deserve it
like it's it's a comp issue i mean it's a little bit of like a player issue too but like ultron ultron is actually not it it's time to play all chicken again to be fair i should be playing invas I definitely should have been playing in this.
I'm ready when you are Angela.
Ready when you are
All right, that's a lot of
Hey guys, he's still like loading What
Nice I'm just reloading there you go There you go.
Go!
Fight this!
Okay, never mind.
That was a battle.
I will admit that was a battle for me.
I will admit that.
I will take flame.
I thought they were... I thought they'd be closer.
I legitimately thought...
That was my bad for thinking they'd be closer.
I didn't realize they would do the...
You know what I didn't realize?
I didn't realize they could kite it.
They could just walk backwards.
Isn't that crazy?
What a crazy concept.
I was just like, holy shit, you can do that.
You can just walk backwards and kite my ult.
Angela, when you farm all, I got you.
Oh no, I know how to do the wall attack.
By the way, you guys didn't see it, but some guy, he wrote raccoon.
But I know how to do the wall attack.
I just never had the moment to...
to do it yet.
You haven't cheered.
Well, apparently not.
Oh, shit.
Broody tooth.
It's behind.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Alright.
I'm healing.
Okay.
Are we going?
We should go with the mantis up.
Yep.
I was gonna say it.
Yeah, yeah.
About that, everyone about that, everyone about that way of time.
There you go.
Kill Guru again, kill Guru.
Kill Guru.
Oh, yo.
We also kill, I don't know, this guy.
On me, on me.
Yeah, there is it.
There is it.
Okay, we're not, we're gonna ignore him.
That's cool.
The Phoenix on the left.
Wait, where did the Phoenix go?
No, our Ultron is a Mantis player.
Oh, fuck.
I wasn't supposed to do that.
Sometimes I accidentally used my jump pack.
That ain't good.
The thing is, it's time to play up chicken again.
Oh, you kidding me?
Yo, buddy, yo.
I'm literally eating.
Rock it all.
Leave rock it all.
Oh my god.
I couldn't do anything about it.
See, it was all chicken.
See it was all chicken.
I had to all chicken it.
I told you, it's literally all chicken.
He won.
He won all chicken.
He fucking won all chicken.
Don't you hate it when they win all chicken?
They actually won all chicken.
The current score is 0, 2, 3.
Time to switch things up, including which side you're on.
I will say we did hold better when I was on Rack I think I'll just have to play in this I don't want to play Luna what is all chicken all chicken is basically um the Phoenix and I have to the thing is as Luna I'll just get targeted by Jeff so it's like because my mag doesn't save his ult to save me so I just get eaten so as Raccoon I can fucking run away easier That's why I still have to Raccoon,
because, uh, as Invis, at least I can go Invisible.
But Alt-Chicken is basically the, the Phoenix holds her alt for, against my alt, because her alt instantly destroys Rocket Alt, and also does damage.
So, like, but if I never alt, she never alts.
And, like, she knows that.
So she never alts, because she has, she's waiting for me to go alt.
So it's, it's, it's Alt-Chicken.
It's like whoever breaks first fucks their team and then I broke because I was getting fucking like because I was getting chased and then like the guy was like you should all you should all and I was like all right it's your fault.
Yeah it's waiting for whoever I the thing is Dylan is a fucking Mantis one trick too which is very annoying because we have two Mantis one tricks
That's why it's like super annoying.
Like, I have to avoid one of the Mantis.
The thing is, I don't know who this other person is, the Chimkin.
But, like, Dylan doesn't swap.
From every time I've, like, had him.
I would sometimes avoid him just because, like, it does.
Because the only way to make this work is if I have another triple support.
Also, the only reason why I don't want to go Luna for him is because this Jeff See?
That's why.
Because he would just solo me.
So it's just not worth it.
Really?
Okay, I think I know who to avoid.
Actually, now I know who to avoid.
No, okay, no.
This is Worse, I'd rather have an Ultron than what I just saw.
I really...
Yeah, no, I would...
Yeah, I'd rather have...
I'd rather have an Ultron.
I'd rather have Dylan on Mantis than this.
Everyone target...
Disappear!
Okay.
That's bad.
Oh, goodbye.
All right
We're not winning this I I have no confident in my team Oh He like was at the weirdest position for that
Nice Jesus Christ chill Holy shit
Yeah, it's a GG.
It is 100% GG.
At least I know it's not me, you know?
At least I know.
I'm at Celestia tier right now, but I haven't played a lot this season.
I think if I played more, maybe I could, like, get to watch.
See, I could just do this.
Okay, at least it's like Oh I mean, I faded They're all out And now I have to leave Wait, what?
What is he doing here?
Wait, he was behind us I will say I will say I have the least amount of deaths.
Oh, yeah, we have not killed the Phoenix at all.
No, okay, no, this is our entire team problem.
No, never mind.
This is a team issue.
We've not killed the Phoenix one time.
This is a team issue at that point.
I didn't even notice the Phoenix.
Alright, I gotta...
Bro, I...
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't know yet.
You know, it's a win if we kill the Phoenix.
He was against the podium.
He was so lucky.
Oh my god.
That was so lucky.
He was actually so lucky.
I'm so sad.
He literally lived because he was against the podium.
him.
Oh my god, I'm trying to... Oh wait, what the fuck?
There we go.
See, look at that, I'm invisible.
Look at that, with the power of... Why can't my... You know what?
No, I have to say, Why can't my mag do that?
He doesn't know.
Oh, he did.
Oh, my God, he did.
Oh, we killed him twice.
We did it.
I don't care if we lose.
We killed him twice.
It's okay.
We got him.
We did it, boys.
We killed him twice.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, no, we're dead.
Zero, two, three.
Yeah, imagine if that...
You know what?
No, I'm going to avoid both the supports, actually.
So I don't have to have two Mantis one tricks.
I'm pretty sure the other Mantis will avoid the other Mantis, but then now I know, like, both of them won't be on my team.
I was out here struggling.
13k?
Really?
I mean, did he get 22k damage, still but still like
all right we can't be having two mantis one tricks together no they'll most likely avoid each other i don't think i was the problem in that entire fight all right how close am i okay thank god i'm not that close God.
As long as I'm not close to Lord,
that's fine.
I think the most thing I'm just concerned about was the fact that either of them did not swap.
But at that point, it wasn't just a support line up.
We were, I don't know.
I mean, I didn't know if our DPS was doing good.
I couldn't tell.
Oops, sorry.
Hello, everyone.
Club Jokeybird is open for business.
That's right.
Come on.
Don't you want to work that pull?
You got to pay for college, don't you?
I'm offering a good cut.
Oh, come on, guys.
Pulls are hard to come by.
Oh, that's true.
He did go Widow.
Oh, I should have avoided the Widow.
Whatever.
It's fine.
Wait, why are these people fighting?
Stop.
Stop, everyone.
We were so peaceful.
Ever since I opened Club Dokey Bird.
Things were so rough.
Oh, I don't even remember.
Someone on our team was on Widow.
even remember when that happened yeah i'm i'm so um generous i'll give you a 10 cut if you work for club dokey babe that's why you should dance next to our queen come on just do you know you want to come on just here i'll demonstrate that that whoa yeah yeah just whoa everyone's a fucking critic I'm like her pet.
I can't believe it.
Everyone's so violent.
I don't understand.
What happened, everyone?
What happened to my RIP servers?
Where's the peace of love?
Peace of love.
I missed my roleplay servers.
Nobody wants the roleplay.
anymore.
Come on.
Any RPAs?
Hey, Rixie.
Trying to open a club, but everyone's so violent.
It's a tough time for a small business owner.
Remember to support your local business owners, guys.
It's so hard to start a business.
Alright, guys.
Come on.
Here's the Paula.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll give you a step one.
You stand on the pull.
Who is he?
That's it.
I'm mad now.
Give me a sec.
I gotta remember how to...
How to unalive in this game.
I...
I got you sick-eyed.
I got you sick-eyed too.
To a different world.
Right after.
I took the wrong way
Rixie, D rank right now I'm Celeste 2 D rank right now Wait, I should Actually, no, it depends on what one above all you are
One above all is not that fun It's not as wild Don't you like the wild demon hour demon cues you're missing out now you have to play meta and dive all the time that's boring who the fuck wants to play that look i got an iron fist in my game
is that exciting
you don't see that every day i have an iron fist I died while role-playing and got transported to world eternal rank matches also I'm gonna go dad real quick he won he's gonna keep barred pick your hero or villain I'm not judging
all right bro me and number seven weren't cheating oh my god do we have hackers Why?
He's meta.
Like, why the fuck did he ban Rocket?
He's actually a good...
Why?
Wait, did I ban him?
Bro, I left.
Oh, wait, I banned...
I went to see...
I can't even realize...
I didn't even...
Why the fuck is that happening?
Why the fuck is no one...
Did no one outbanned me?
I...
Fast and peace sabotage.
Bro, why did no one outbanned me?
What happened?
Did I win the...
Did I win the gacha?
Was it 25%?
What is...
Bro, I was feeding my dog!
Oh, I was the only one that banned...
Okay, they can't blame me.
I was...
I'd just be like, I fucked up.
I will admit that I've fucked up.
That's crazy.
I won the bad.
Bro, they're running Mantis Jeb.
We should...
Alright, it's fine.
I wish I was Rocket.
I can't believe it.
Nobody stopped me.
nobody's fucking stopped me they cannot blame me no one stopped me there okay they're fucking loud they're trying to because i was gonna say there's no way that our mag lives this jesus now we're not winning this unless we like swap up our comp but i don't know if that's
How should I push it up with it?
Oh, I got scared.
At least my team lives.
No, I should do the Scythe and push up with that.
But I, like, reactionary.
I did a reactionary for that.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Okay.
I was like, wait, did his...
I was like, what the fuck happened?
I was like, did they like... Oh my god, oops.
Wee!
Yeah, we might need more help.
Like, there's no way that their comp should be winning against our comp.
Because, like, they should not have enough heals, but they're just winning the brawl faster than...
Then we can heal it.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
I have to use this.
It's fine.
As long as we stay in our little cubby hole, right?
The thing is, he might ult now.
Because I don't really have anything for it.
Oh my god I have to be so aware This is why I hate This is why I miss playing raccoons I have to be so fucking aware About everything I'm gonna try and let our I want to let our Luna heal But like
Jesus Christ I can't They're so okay Okay Are we just getting blocked?
No, the Iron Fist is, like, not doing so well.
Yeah, there's no.
No, our Iron Fist is not doing anything.
We should, theoretically, like, like, theoretically, we should win this just because...
Actually, no, we shouldn't because we have a 9% that does jack shit.
Yes, you're...
makes you you're missing out.
Iron Fist and Wolverine?
You're missing out, bro.
Losing to a Mantis Jeff Heel cop.
Well, that could be you right now.
That could be us.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I could technically play Jeff, but I don't know how to play Jeff.
You know what?
Today's the day I learned.
is it winnable we'll find out we'll find out it's time to learn maybe i'm a natural you don't know that i could be a natural jeff player all my hours of jeff was literally last season
he is meta i just the way i play it might not be meta Oh my god, I'm eating candy!
Oh.
Me being on Jeff does not make the reason why he died.
It's not the reason why we died.
Okay.
Um.
It's, I will say, it's not my fault.
I died here.
Me on Jeff is...
Oh, I have Halloween music.
That's cool.
That's cute.
All right, now we leave.
Oh my god, my reload has Halloween music too.
That's so cute.
That's cute, I like that.
Alright, here we go.
I have ult.
I don't know how to use it, but I have ult.
This is my biggest weakness as Jeff.
I literally don't know how to use my ult.
Oh, I can use it to eat him.
There we go.
Never mind.
I got him, though.
I got him.
Alright, guys.
I have a feeling Jeff was not it.
Back to meta.
I got what?
Look, I had my one.
I had my eat.
But how come there, Jeff, can do that?
I don't understand.
How could they chip do all of that?
All right.
Oh, yeah.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
It won't be fine, but, like, it's okay.
I can cope.
All right.
It's all about coping.
We didn't have a single kill, but that's...
okay it's not because of a oh oh he's gonna be like legendary yeah this guy's been saving leg I think he's just like doing a challenge I swear
what oh my god he timed it perfectly oh my god he actually oh he timed it perfectly.
That's so unfair.
I fucking heartbeat it.
I should put it closer to me.
I didn't think that Mag was, like, zoned in on me.
Yeah.
I thought, because, like, I was, to be fair, it was four of us clumped together, and then I thought the Mag was, like, not looking at me.
So I was like, I can get away with this.
I could get away with it.
That'll be fine.
Oh no, that team was very special.
Yo, my bad team.
What the fuck?
Can't Duke a Duke a Duke a Duke.
Yo, my bad.
Yeah, he's just like, oh, I'm sorry, bro.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
My bad team is playing like ass.
At least he apologized.
Don't worry, I'll give you a show and a dinner.
I'll be back.
I'm back.
It's time.
What the fuck is Gail still doing today?
Whoa, yeah, the full frontal and everything?
You know what?
I'm gonna make someone's birthday today.
First time catching the stream and it's Venom twerking.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Mr. President.
Happy birthday.
What the fuck?
What is this?
This is a birthday, not war.
Hello, Loki.
Hello.
Happy birthday, dear Mr. President.
Look at that.
Booty can save lives.
They all stop fighting.
Look at that.
Bro, come on.
Don't run.
You like this.
Come on.
Don't run.
That's right.
What you doing?
Huh?
Come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's your birthday.
Happy birthday, Mr. President.
Please stop.
Yeah, they stopped fighting around us.
Look at that.
Whoa!
Double the clones.
I don't vibe with that.
Don't worry, I can fix them.
Don't worry, everyone.
We can fix them.
Watch this.
I can fix this man.
Why are you so violent, bro?
Bro, why are you so violent?
I'm here to fix you.
I'm here to bring joy.
to your life.
Where are you?
Don't fucking run away.
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, I lost him.
Oh, here you go.
That's right.
Don't worry, bro.
I'm here to give you some joy.
Come on.
Come on, bro.
It's your birthday.
Happy.
Look at that.
I told you.
Booty saves lives.
Look, he's so happy.
He's giving...
He's clapping.
I told you guys see he stopped being violent He's praying to the guys that he got these cheeks I do not let him clap I told you I can stop violence Everyone stop fighting
Everyone stop fighting Bro bro stop fight no no no no here Happy birthday Dude.
Oh, guys!
Made them praise the sun.
You praise the moon, that's for sure.
It's okay.
They just don't appreciate fine dining.
I'm so funny.
Hey, there.
Is it your birthday, too?
I'm here to inspire people.
That's right.
You feel inspired now?
You want to go to war?
for this booty he did this like i just slowly slowly backing to the ass he's like contemplating he's like zoomed in examining
venom no
venom he's locked in he's hypnotized by the booty he can't stop looking he can't stop
i swear i do not recognize any of these names i think it's just because like everyone else is higher elonel
yeah the symbiotic mind control it always works guys it just works it just works it just works
Don't ban Rocket by accident.
Why did no one out ban me?
Did they not find it fucking weird that I banned Rocket?
Out of any character.
I said, well, I was the only one that had...
And I was like, who the fuck banned Rocket?
And it was like, you banned Rocket.
And I'm like, me?
When did that happen?
Why the fuck did that happen?
That's crazy.
There's no way it was me.
Yeah, it's Rival is at 6 a.m.
for me.
Has Big Bird even told me?
The time?
Okay, Big Bird.
Uh, with a day tomorrow.
Hey.
Have you figured out the day?
yet i'm just wondering have you figured have you figured out a day yet all right just because i need to post my schedule like later yeah the sgc play oh yeah if you missed out the beginning of the stream um um i am getting additional coaching by big bird yeah yeah talked about in the beginning of the
Yeah, because I was like, you know, big bird, angry bird, and dokey bird.
I'm collecting all the...
I just need angry bird, then.
And now I collected all the birds.
Speaking of which, if you're looking for planets to burn, I know a few that disturb it.
They'll put it here.
All the birds.
What the fuck?
Oh, the portal.
Yeah, with the power of birds I remember when like when strange would get like his all just from doing that But you can build up like 70 all charge from it Yeah
We're doing it guys Let me go
Look, if we win this game, I'll play a real support character.
I'm just chilling.
After the shit game I had last game, I get to chill now.
After accidentally banning Rocket, I am allowed to chill.
I am not chill maxing now.
Wait, what?
Who the fuck destroyed my...
Who the fuck destroyed my res?
Oh?
How the fuck did I get up?
So confused.
What did I do?
I don't even know how I got my ult that fast, honestly.
This was a lot faster than I expected.
You know, fuck it.
I'm gonna up before our Luna ups.
I should up before our Luna does it.
In case we actually double support up.
trust myself there you go hello there you don't know look at that they don't know see look i see them i'm a hero you're welcome my paypal is here's my paypal look at that press right click so
so i was gonna just stand I was like, what are you gonna do?
Kill me?
While I stand in the open?
That's crazy.
That's never gonna happen.
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
How many ults are we using, guys?
Guys!
Alright, I believe in my team.
Oh my god, everything.
Okay, now we've actually use all our elves don't worry I'm coming back guys live there you go don't worry you should be res from this I do it I'm so smart that was the smartest res I could do oh good luck don't worry I'm here just take this there They don't know.
I'm in the waterfall.
They can't see shit.
Alright.
They might destroy it.
No, they're too stupid.
Nice.
Look at that.
They don't know.
The water conceals me.
I'm a water panda now.
Look at that.
Easy.
Alt city.
Now we have no else.
I believe in my team.
I have to reload, but I'm doing my best.
Okay, they don't know that I have a res beacon here.
What are they going to do?
Look up?
That's crazy, Todd.
See, look at that.
See, I told you.
I'm just trying to make sure she lives.
Are you serious?
No, he was 99.
That's so unlucky.
He was 99.
99.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Why are you still looking at me?
Wait.
That's okay.
He's not looking at me.
It's okay.
I'm right below him.
He's the easiest game of my life.
He's the easiest game.
Time to switch things up.
I'm hitting him like he's like.
He'll never know.
Like how he's like, I don't know where she is.
I'll just stop.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Don't let Doki get away with this.
I told you, yeah, no object permanence.
He doesn't see me.
He's like, where were these healers coming from?
Not my problem, I guess.
The crazy part was that guy was fucking chasing me for so long, too.
And the moment I went right below him, he was just like, fuck that shit.
That's too much work.
My neck can't go down that far.
Uh, Charles, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Durs, thank you for the 100 bitties.
You see our poor Luna getting chased after by that Captain America?
And then you see me just standing still healing?
Yeah, this is why I don't play Luna anymore.
Why make it harder for myself if I can just do this to get to Celestia?
I understand now.
Yeah, I'm still standing.
There's no way they can shoot this.
The thing is, we can still lose.
Only because that...
Because they did cap it a little.
So it is loosable.
What the fuck?
How did he die?
I thought Arluna was healing the rock, the cap, not talking, Angela.
Sorry, it took three tries, but I got it eventually.
Eventually I'll get the right character.
Yeah, she built the same ult charge as me.
So it's like, how the fuck did Arluna?
like whoa whoa the perfect calendar fist i i did think i thought the luna would heal me when i dashed in front of her but i guess like i just don't have rights because i'm an animal
like which is understandable i i get that i get it i get it i get it i get it
Surprisingly, Iron Fist is like a counter to Rocket.
Only because they, uh...
Oh my god, what is this team doing?
Okay, here we go.
We do have...
Because I don't know where that is going.
Oh there it is.
There you go.
Here you go.
I'll just chill here.
I live here now.
This is where I live.
You know what sucks?
I think the enemy team already used Puerto.
Oh, never mind.
That was our Puerto.
I mean...
I'm doing it.
Oh.
A little too late there, buddies.
I'm just gonna give it to the Angelo over there.
Just a little too late.
Oh my god, catch it, catch it.
Whoops, sorry.
Yay!
See, they don't know how to look up or down.
Who would...
Yay!
I feel so safe.
You see what our Luna had to go through?
And then you see where I had to go through?
Let me...
Let me show you the replay.
Final score.
One, two, zero.
You're like, I can't believe it, Doki.
You sold out.
You were our number one raccoon hater.
What happened to you?
I will show you what happened to me.
I will show you.
Yay!
And I got more healing.
Let's fucking go.
Alright, here we go.
There's a reason why I don't play this character anymore.
I know I keep saying it, but I need to give you more confirmation.
Because people always say, Doki, what happened?
Why are you on?
Why are you on this character?
Let me...
Let me show you why.
So you see me?
You see I'm just, like, having a good time.
And then our Luna is just dancing.
You see that?
Now, what is going on?
on the Luna side while all of this was going on.
Well, the way there it go.
The way there it go.
And now, all done.
And then what's going on on my side?
Yay.
Oh, yeah.
all right how about like here what's going on on um the lunar side oh yeah look at that oh that looks that looks so fun and it's going on my side we
Yay!
Alright, let's see.
Okay, and then...
And then what was going on on Luna's side again?
Alright, look, he's happy.
Oh, there she is, look at that.
And what's going on on my end?
Weeeee!
Oh yeah, this is where I got my coroner.
Yay!
So yeah, that's why I'm now a non-luna enjoyer.
Yeah, like, bro, there's nothing I could do.
I fucking try to heal her.
Hey, it's like a good thing.
the fuck down why would i get down i threw orbs at her that's all i could do what do you want me to do get down so i also die like my heels travel like i can travel to you it's not my fault it's just too much damage like maybe you should have positioned better i don't know maybe you should learn how to jump i or crawl walls it was just that easy maybe maybe you should have learned how to climb walls there was no there was no saving she had three people beating the shit out of her there was no saving that i saw what i saw three people were fucking pummeling her all i could do was watch
Maybe he should position better by a raccoon on a roof who tells me, yeah, like, why couldn't you get up?
You should have took my, you should have took my jump pack and then jumped to the roof and then we could have both been on the roof.
That's on you.
I don't know.
Oh, it's like that, what is this, like that lead game where, um, the one guy was like, What song was he singing?
He's singing a Maroon 5 song, and then it cuts his eyes like, and he's like,
And he's like, yeah, yeah,
and then it cuts to the, to the loot.
I'm just like Just on my high ground roof No
Any RPers Any RP enjoyers I love that video That's literally me playing rocket Versus like any other support I think it's also That's why I'm more chill now So I mean dive is crazy now like dive is like hard meta and like uh the reason why na got destroyed was because like na is so bad with dive and like because he can't do anything they're not used to playing against dive because like people in na don't fucking play dive but everyone in eu plays dive because all the fucking venom players are i think like all the best venom players are the best venom and are EU.
So, like, it's so easy to play dive for it's so easy to practice and play dive for them.
But in NA, everyone is like stationary.
Like, everyone's still, like, on they're on, like, what, Mag and Strange and Groot and shit.
So, like, no one's like, or Emma.
They still play, like, Mag, Emma, and Strange and stuff.
So, so it's so hard for people, for them to adjust to dive.
And it's not fun.
It's like, as a support player, it's not.
It's like the black back, the black, the back line is non-existent.
Yeah, the best captain, no, it's actually crazy.
The best Captain America player in, in Marble Rivals isn't even American.
It's not even American.
I think it's like, it's either like, what, Nevix or Finzi?
Is that crazy?
The best of Captain America player is European.
Captain Europe.
You should get a team skin and then make Captain Europe.
That would be cool.
I think that's one thing I hope Marvel...
I don't actually know they can't do it because I don't think Marvel would let them do that.
It would have been cool like Overwatch where remember in OWL in Overwatch League, if a team wins the grand finals, you get to make a skin, basically.
for winning.
But I don't think, I don't think Marvel would allow that.
I think Marvel would be like, we are not letting you make OCs based off of, uh, like without our permission.
I heard like, because like Marvel is very protective of their property.
I don't know.
I don't know what Marvel would or wouldn't let you do.
Because I heard that like Marvel is like really hard to work with for licensing.
Because like, they're very very I can't obviously I can't say which brand told me but one I was trying to do a brand because like I was like oh do you think I could do like a I play Marvel rivals a lot do you think I could do like a collab or cross like a collab merch with Marvel rivals and then they're like oh um they were like oh um we can't do that because like Marvel is very hard to work with because they
that they like yeah they're and they're copyrighted they're like oh yeah no like we're not planning on working with Marvel in the future because like it was so difficult doing like a collab with them because they were so so like particular about like certain things oh were there weirdos in my chat I didn't even notice oh sorry here don't worry you want to dance don't worry i'll heal you did that heal you
yeah but they're very like um they're very anal about like what they can do with their ip like they're very specific about how the merchandising is done and stuff i did i cured her in my soul all right i'll play it we haven't even started the game three dps on defense it's never gonna work no what do you want who said that uh it's a group you said that i don't think uh three dps is just obviously i think we should have four dps yeah i don't think there's enough dps guys look riggs you're missing out you don't get this one above all what group man what in the world bro hawkeye is broken what are you saying you're missing out right now we got some doors we got a bander double i mean how am i throwing look at that character can one shot how's that broken oh yeah it's broken we gotta look at that we even get a hawkeye fan he can literally just perma stay alive he like eats bullets what the is going huh why are we trolling band phase bro no one's trolling You're not trolling.
This is how you bam.
You're just a bad player, bro.
Let me know what you think.
Yeah, you aren't up with a meta.
Okay, bro.
My bad.
I wasn't familiar with her game, King.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
All right.
Go group.
I'm playing Moon Knight.
All right.
Got you, buddy.
You know, I love this.
This is a really bad conference.
I don't think like anyone is on the same page.
No, I just said it.
Rocket open.
Oh, my bad.
would you fuck all right we let's okay yeah i won't play support yeah the zoom meeting sucks i got you low back bro the zoom meeting is so bad we're not on the right we're not on the right you're not you're not looking at the right thing bro because this account is literally 600 low peak fucking oh guess i'm on rocket dude yeah you see a spider i know i'm a beast oh yeah you're a beast This meeting could have been guys,
this could have been an email guys.
Did you not read my five page briefing of this Tachala map?
Literally the worst report in the game.
Hello guys.
Did you guys hear about the new DDoS, the new DDoS hacks?
What would you know about that?
Yeah.
Well Matt, did you hear about it?
He committed lobbies crash.
Yeah.
weird watch out oh that's so weird it would be a shame if it happens right now it would be a shame
oh my god that's crazy wow oh we should push the hulk got dmx and stuff this is like where we should be a shame come on any minute now i'm shooting mr fantastic i'm gonna hook group i checked let's go to me but yeah i wasn't even here there bro what the are you I'm shooting the group right now.
This is all I can do.
I'm shooting Groot right now.
Nice.
He did it.
He shot Groot, guys.
I'm going in.
He's still shooting him.
He's still doing it.
Cypher's lurking.
Cypher lurking garage.
Shooting Spider-Man.
Okay, he's shooting.
He's shooting.
I'm hooking Hulk.
Heal me.
What do you mean?
You're fully healed.
Oh my god.
I'm ulting him.
I'll shoot you.
Shoot Jeffrey.
Oh my god.
We lived.
I don't know how.
We lived a silo.
That's crazy.
No, I'm not.
I've never seen that before.
I've never seen us living through a silo.
Hey, hey buddy.
Hey, we got Doki.
Oh my god, it's me.
Is that the pedophile?
No, no, no.
Oh, okay.
I'm sorry.
What?
Why?
Got him.
Can we get that?
Oh, big damage.
Big damage.
Big news.
I don't know where he heard that.
The story.
Because I'm going to go to HR, guys.
HR.
Help me.
Him is trolling.
Shoot him.
Oh, dude.
They're cute.
Why did you- Again, again, no one's shooting George.
Why did you say anything?
You didn't say you're not.
I know, because I am not a PDF guy.
Shoot him, shoot him, shoot him.
This guy, I'm going to HR.
This Zoom meeting is crazy.
I need to go to HR right now.
I am gro- Oh, I am gro- Hit him, hit him, hit him.
I'm dead.
See you guys.
Dang it.
He's so old.
Yo.
Wait, he got four.
I'm at four.
Run back.
We're good.
Oh, he's fucking dead.
Shoot it.
Shoot Hulk.
I'm punching him.
Hit him.
Shoot him.
Keep going.
When do we stop?
All right.
I'm coming back.
I didn't see this guy.
I didn't see B.
When do we stop?
Hey, too.
This is real fire.
I think we're gonna kill him, right?
Yeah.
All right.
Shoot Groot.
I'm shooting.
No, we're not.
That's unlucky.
He's not siloed.
You're siloed right now.
We lost.
Here's siloed.
Call 3, 2, 1, go, go, go, go.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
Heal me, heal me, heal me.
Heal me, heal me.
Oh.
I'm on it.
I'm healing.
I forgot about the siloed.
We got TB.
We'll do it just yet.
Oh, you dumb baka.
Oh, that was a bit too close on the ground.
Get in there.
get in there he's such a dumb baka you guys are all my god
am i are people okay i can't tell bro i just caught my rock man oh my god oh yep we did it but it's just i mean i mean i'll try my tiny gun so unfortunate bro My tiny pistol.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
Me and the cloak, we got this.
So, where's my Super Gomez?
Okay, the game will be over right now.
I love Super Gomez.
He and them are best friends.
Jeff is not dying when he owns.
Where's my Super Gomez?
Shoot, Groot.
I got a big hook.
Big hook.
God, I'm on me.
Look at this guy.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Kill me, kill me, kill me.
heal me heal me where's my super don't worry i'm right clicking i'm right clicking yeah where is he uh where is he i can't believe he would go to a land what a loser having friends
what a loser no i'm shooting this guy ah gg too early of a mag rock what a noob bro what a loser i'm going in i got i got Nice.
Got him.
All right.
Let's push on.
Go, go, go, go.
Go on, go on.
Go on, go.
Go on.
I'm gonna respond.
When the world needed him, he had to go to the stupid thing.
Groot on me.
Invis on me.
They're all on me.
All on me.
Oh my god, they're actually working together.
Shoot them, shoot them, shoot them, shoot them, shoot them.
There you go.
This is real firepower.
I'll see you.
All right, guys.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
They burned your ult.
It matters so much.
It matters so much, guys.
I mean, we have no Super Gomez on my team.
I'm sorry.
I'll try to be Super Gomez.
What do you mean?
Where my cloak and dagger are now?
I'm waiting for it.
Oh my god, oh my, he got juggled so far.
Oh my, I don't know what's going on.
I don't know what's going on.
Heal me, heal me, heal me.
I'm trying.
I'm at 97 of my ult, bro.
Oh, this is bad.
Remember me?
I never get ult like that.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
Man, deep guys.
ran with the jet pole yo um hope open by the way off meta king yeah hope what's up i said oh no it's going so bad no no no use your own don't do that just yet use your own press q and use your own just press q but okay i'm the one i'm i'm the one to charge the jet ball okay you can't you can't trust that guy he's a magic player but you we got mad graphed that three times yeah bro how is he he He can't trust this guy.
I'm my too.
He's a magic player, bro.
You don't know what he's gonna do.
You don't know.
Heal me, heal me, heal me.
I'm trying.
This is all I can do.
Shooting, I'm shooting, I'm shooting, I'm shooting.
God, I'm God, I'm God.
He's one.
Did he use it?
Oh my God, he did it.
Who is he eating?
Okay, we, oh shit.
Okay, he's fine.
spawn just your spot you think you think I'm he's getting healed they do have got him okay they do have silo I don't know if TLC we just did I don't know if fight their spawn get in here walk in the room guys fight them fight them fight them we have to have 1 HP
okay he can die I don't think he's dying
that's I don't think he's dying anymore.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Yeah, he wasn't.
He literally came up to me just to solo ult me.
You fucking freak.
You actual freak.
Alright, winnable, winnable.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Setting up for a big Ironman ult.
Big Ironman.
No, no, no, no.
Where'd my Groot ult go?
I can get Groot in time.
Yeah, you will, if you believe.
You just gotta believe, bro.
Okay, now I don't...
Oh, this is...
Oh, hello.
I'm here now.
Oh!
Can we make sure...
This guy dies?
Can we...
You know...
Where might all go?
Heal me, heal me, heal me.
point i got him i got him oh my god he did it he did say he got him nice good old hey guys there is a jeff nice what's wrong guys the current score is i don't even know who he is guys we got them to overtime three times i'd say he has five orbs run at him all right guys what's the play y'all i'm gonna say uh say group go hold i'll actually i actually do play i'm not gonna follow your heart
babe who do you trust dokey brain that's good or i like apples 873 the fact that there is a fact that someone already took i like apples and he has to go to 873 like 73 does that mean you like 873 apples or is that just there's just 873 people that like exposed on twitter for doing bad things you got exposed on twitter for doing bad Thanks.
Thank you for confessing to me, bro.
He got 15 likes and two retweets.
W, bro.
I'll do the...
People who like Tappos are trustworthy.
No, I'm the guy who recreated the Peterbot video inside of Sinatra's game.
The what?
Peter?
Why are he's famous?
Wait, is that actually a video on Twitter, right?
Just because, like, I'm trying to test it.
Peterbot, Morton Marlborough.
No, I wish, though.
That would be pretty good.
Yeah, weird flex, but okay.
I've never played Storm, by the way.
I don't know how to play this character, so I'm just...
Stay low to the ground, alright.
Low to the ground, low to the ground.
He's learning, he's learning, everyone.
I got this to speed boost.
I'm pressing me.
I'm right-clicking.
Yeah, just right-click, left-click, right-click, right-click.
This is the best time to learn.
I want damage.
Wait, we're running triple support?
Oh my gosh, we had so many heals going in.
Help me, help me, help me.
Oh, we had so...
I'm backing, I'm backing, I'm swapping damage.
Yep, just say, remember to stay low on the ground.
How the fuck did they have a lot of damage?
Yeah, how is there a Jeff guy?
No one shot, bro.
So why are you peeking?
I'm backing us, I'm backing us.
Guys, this ain't looking so good.
This is looking a little rough.
Thanks.
How are we speeding us?
Okay, I had a look.
Got these.
Oh, guys, we're going yet.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, how do I do this?
How do I do this?
I'm pressing Q.
I'm doing it.
Got him?
He's doing it.
I got A.
You think they're doing it, guys?
Judge, jury, executioner.
I'm speeding my team.
I am doing everything.
Oh my god, Kobe.
Look at that.
Why am I moving?
I could literally just...
I'm speeding you guys.
He's going for me.
I'm in the air.
He can't get me.
Oh.
Yeah, that's a lot of damage.
Autumn.
Swapping damage.
Especially me.
I don't know what this does.
Oh, they portal.
They had enough time to portal this.
oh no changing the air changing the air one changing the air one changing the air one no change is not near one he's actually it's okay i have the high ground this is the longest style of my alt oh that's awkward that's so awkward i how are they doing so much damage you know bro like my team full of noobs like no they'll be killed hope all right no one's so much damage.
I don't understand.
We have three people.
No, don't do that.
Where's my Super Gomez?
It's right here, bro.
Super Gomez at home.
Super Gomez at home, bro.
Yeah, back.
Super Gomez at home.
Super Gomez at T-Move.
I have my ult here, bro.
I'm going to ult this.
I'm going to ult this walk around here.
you after five people got ulted i'm down i don't love you we trust you like 10 years after we opened sales that's unlucky they died too fast i live through it and then they died so fast i might have timu team too i'm old chipper
does not know how to play support he does he's a really good mantis but every time i'm holding support and i'm on support it's like the most stressful game ever okay well i don't think i got i don't think i got any heels because i don't have anything i have to jump in a rocket
i'm alive oh big venom all big venom are coming no longer alive oh my god this is massive yeah I think we may or may not have we may or may not have fucked around and found out strange portal up you need to get on the point ASAP gotta get on the point ASAP gotta get on the point oh I was alive no you guys came
Yeah, I think, um, maybe, uh, you know, at least we had a good team building exercise, at least, right?
At least, yeah, one out of five.
I hate all of you.
I think this guy might put him in his two weeks, guys.
I think he might quit the company.
why i felt like it was a very productive student meeting we definitely got a lot of work done yeah there might have been several hr violations but like you know at least we all had a good time right there's always one guy that's gonna quit all right rixie ready you ready i denied it you mean I did not the allegations I don't know what the fuck you're talking about I did not have I did not do any of that from a guy who from a from a fucking guy called I like apples do you just believe any allegations his name was I like apples 873
where was his sources his sources is like sources trust me bro like
what if he's for the people he likes apples and i like apples
oh yeah what happened remember when do you remember this that was a good day i missed this day I heard he actually likes oranges Yeah I heard he's actually an orange lover I don't even know who fucking performed like the worst Out of our entire team My team was so special
My team was actually like So special
It's so stressful Trust me bro Heal me, heal me, heal me Group 1, group 1 We
guard the galaxy sure, but sometimes we take stuff other people are gonna shoot him shoot him shoot him Wait, weren't they wasn't one of them advertising Was it him I don't even know if that's a real twitch Hold on oh there's another bit I was like I didn't talk to nobody
You should play with...
I would like to have...
Okay, that's it.
That's it.
What's your name?
Okay.
I'm gonna find you.
I was trying to be peaceful.
Alright, give me a sec.
This time I won't get Isakai.
How do I...
Give me a sec.
Alright, where is he?
Was it G not...
G-Nop.
Okay.
I don't remember how to get out of here.
First stop.
Let me figure out how to get out of here.
Yeah, I was trying to be nice.
Hey.
Hey, I don't...
I'm not here to fight you.
I have someone else I'm gonna fight.
Okay, no.
Not him.
Where is he?
Where's the fucking blade?
Oh, shit.
No, that's...
That's not...
The fight's not here with you.
Alright, there you go.
Bro!
What the fuck?
I'm just chilling!
You show.
Thank you, the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Fullybear.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, where is he?
He won't leave me alone.
Let the man sit.
I'm still trying to find this fucking blade.
Where the fuck is this guy?
Is that him?
Yeah, fuck this guy.
He can't have fun.
That's right.
I'm trying to be a successful small business owner.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright, I'll play a real support.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Don't worry guys.
I will finally play a real support character.
oh wednesday nice for big bird yeah that works for me wednesday 9 p.m all right there you go i thought you were cool i was cool and then he messed with me why have i accidentally abandoned this a real support character wild oh shit widow maker on widow maker
I hope our one this one guy and our team actually plays a tank Oh, yeah, do you guys know the new like oh my gosh Okay, I don't know if it like abuses like you know, there's like collab What's it called when people like knock knock on other people stream and then they combine their viewership and shit What's that called?
For twitch share chat no not just share chat, but it's like share viewership too apparently people are like the new meta right now to get on the top of the yeah the stream together so the new meta right now to get on the top of the um the top of the the streamer um page for your game is that a bunch of people would just do a stream together but they won't be streaming together because they can they all combine their viewership that they will hit the top column um they'll hit like the top two columns where those who are sorting from high to low a lot of people doing that that's really smart it is but it's also like they're not actually streaming so i see like a bunch of like i see like a bunch of smaller streamers like the new meta like a bunch of smaller streamers they like basically just um combine their viewership together like six people will combine like six plus people um yeah it's a little loophole just a little loophole so like maybe they'll have like 50 viewers or like 100
viewers but when you add all of them together, it'll be like, you know, it'll be like a thousand or something.
It'll be at the top of the, the category.
I see it in rivals, but I don't know, I don't know if it's for other games as well, but I see it a lot in rivals.
The thing is stream together, you don't have to share your chat.
You can like turn that off, like turn that function off.
Like, I've seen people like, You can turn, I know like you can turn it off, so.
It's not an actual, like, you don't have to have share chat.
So it works out.
Or I have to give our, hello, some heals right there.
There you go.
Hey, I gave you shield.
Please respond.
Oh my god, I couldn't help him.
The shield doesn't help that.
Jesus Christ.
I have to scratch myself too.
I have to scratch my face.
Almost have up.
I don't know if I'll get it in time, though.
Alright, we have Emma.
Hey, can we...
Oh, guess not.
Ha ha!
I guess not.
Okay, let's just lift them.
Walk up through each other.
That's cool.
That's fine.
You know?
That's okay.
Where am I?
Hey, why can't you guys burn their oz like you burn my oz?
Guys, it's not fair.
There you go.
I mean, I lived.
That's...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Yeah, I pushed them all in.
at that plan guys i definitely planned that look at that that's right i definitely meant to push yeah all of me guys i pushed all of them into the oh
okay um unfortunate i had a shield though and everything i guess i'll heal myself Just a little heal.
Oh god.
This is a little awkward.
I am a little scared.
Oh, this is a little scary.
Are you serious?
Okay, I just got scared of.
Alright, that's fine.
You got born again.
Holy shit.
What the fuck is that damage?
Oh no, I'm fucking dead.
I'm dead.
Oh, unless...
Oh,
thank god.
Guys, I don't feel good about the Mantis and Invisios.
I'm playing Grit.
Oh, bye Rigsie.
Jesus Christ.
I would do shield mana.
Oh, hey guys.
Can we also destroy that?
That would be so cool.
You know?
I would love to heal.
I'm not doing anything wrong because I have 9.
I am MVP.
Oh, never mind.
I don't give up so easily.
MVP hey guys this doesn't look like the game that we're hoping for it yeah it's looking at oh thank God okay I can actually I'll play Luna then because I can actually have the the power up the team up I'll use my ult though for it there you go I got it all goodbye
oh he blocked i didn't even see the shield it was so cluttered there were so many things on my screen hey guys i'm scared about this guy
hello hey we should help her there you go hey oh shit I am a nice hello little guy hey why didn't we not stagger him we could have staggered him guys he doesn't fuck that guy I don't like how he looks but yeah fuck him in particular I like the way he looks at me oh we don't even have animal yet guys guys i'm taking damage because we linked together and i don't like that oh my god oh my god why why would you put me down why would you put me here oh why did you put me here oh my god he can't dps or fucking
Don't worry riggzy
Okay I should not have trusted my mantis I very low
That that was a mistake he was like don't worry I have a and I was like Really Oh my god!
Well, to be fair, he was in the corner.
I was like, oh my god!
He does!
No, I'm not confident right now.
This guy is just walking up to us.
No, they're just...
They may or may not be just better.
That's it.
Don't worry.
I got res.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
Oh, yeah, I forgot to go Luna.
Oops.
My whole plan was that I should be going Luna.
I forgot all about it.
Look, they just kept pushing, guys.
They just kept pushing.
No, I think they're just...
I think they're just better.
I think their team is just better than...
Seriously, I don't think there's a justification
It's just unfortunate they're built different
Oh, now we don't go at him come on guys Honestly, we just need more damage They're not going dive so I can play and you know Alright, this time We got it this time
Widowmaker not on Widowmaker Fucking fried They're goddamn fried The battle starts in five might as well uninstall Fucking clickbait
I'm still not happy about the I don't know the The Mantis...
Uh...
Mantis duo here?
Because this guy better be hitting all the fucking headshots in his life.
Oh!
That's awkward.
Guys, I don't know, guys.
Try my best to keep you up.
But I don't know anymore.
Oh my god, you're getting so much use.
Holy shit.
That Mr. Fantastic was literally just W keying into us and winning.
How is that possible?
I don't know, fuck are they just a...
I am Groot.
And then I leave.
I got me and so go.
Oh.
That's a lot of ups, guys.
And you know what they have?
A good old juicy atom.
Oh.
Here we go.
Oh, he broke it.
That's good.
Oh.
Ready?
Are you guys ready?
There we go.
Born again.
Oh.
Who would have thought?
Who could have expected that?
Who could have expected a born again?
It's okay.
Wait, we win?
Wait, what is this?
I've never heard that concept before.
Okay, guys.
We're fine.
I've clapped.
Patty kick, patty kick.
Okay, guys.
The gun cart, please help.
Yeah, there's just one guy.
One guy.
Oh.
Ooh, oh, one.
Just one little guy.
I don't think I should have to use this.
There is a raccoon above us.
And he's using the greatest strat of them all, high ground.
point keep up the momentum it's just they don't have dive so i could just put a luna freely i could literally just heal where like nothing could kill me until they run at me that's like the only counter he just got oh oh my god there's no saving this man oh my god
It's just everything.
Oh!
Shit, I'm sorry!
There's nothing I can do!
Bro!
It's just all damage.
It's just all...
Nah, they don't know how to play that.
We're in NA.
How the fuck would they know how to play that?
That's crazy.
Hey guys, I would...
Thank you.
Damn!
I knew they were, yeah, I had a feeling.
I can ult at the Luna.
That's silly.
You think they're gonna know how to do that?
You know what region we're in.
When are they alting?
I'm still waiting for this.
Ugh.
I hit you, I hit you.
The assault, the assault.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
I know that's unfortunate.
There's nothing I can do.
I...
Better kick it out here if we're gonna save the tree.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
Someone out got you.
You should have free bunny or someone else.
Alright.
I...
I wonder if like if one tricks like hate themselves you know like why would you do something to make your life more miserable you know like how could you just play i mean i guess mantis is not that i think it's not that man this is like okay fun but like you know when you're like when you've like played clearly mantis is not working you're still brute forcing mantis i'm just like thinking like Do you hate your life?
How does that work?
How much do you hate yourself to one-trick a character?
Yeah, I will play my one-trick and if I don't, I will die.
I'm just...
I'm out, I'm out, I'm so out.
Oh my god, I got stuck, I got stuck.
I got stuck on the cart.
Because the cart pushed me forward.
Sad.
I'm so upset.
Oh, I'm gigawalking.
Oh, yeah, I'm walking.
Oh.
I shouldn't use that.
Oh, I'm walking.
Yo, there is a atom here.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I shouldn't have altered that.
I freaked out.
No, I threw there.
I panicked.
Press from Reflex there.
It was really Reflex there from me doing that.
We're here.
We might lose that because I accidentally lost it.
Zoning out.
Oh, good.
Oh, we're walking?
Oh, never mind.
We're walking.
We win this.
Back in.
He's threat.
There we go.
Okay, now that's a zoning out.
That's a zoning out.
That's a zoning up.
That's a that's a double zoning up.
That's a There was no reason for us
There was no reason for us to look that That's another zoning up Oh
oh my god please please oh my god they're coming they want to win holy they want to win so badly yes you're a trinity why aren't you getting a hundred 100 kills.
Yeah.
A pro would get 100 kills.
100 kills or throw?
Like 100 kills or kick?
Try his hardest in GM challenge.
oh yeah spark how are you representing eu if you can't even pull off a sparker
toxic you might as well be an You might as well move to NA because you play like an NA player
I'm joking what the fuck Oh shit There is a sidewalk right here Oh shit So I could wouldn't have died there That's all I'm saying.
Feta, Feta, Feta, Feta, Feta, Feta, Feta one, Feta one, Feta one!
I'm all in them, I'm all in them.
They're TP in, they're TP in, I think.
Yep, TP, TP, TP.
All I'm saying is that...
There you go.
Wow, he got there too early, buddy.
And man, Sparkle wouldn't die there.
Again!
There you go.
Nice.
See, no, this is motivation, guys.
Motivation.
I'm just motivating him, chat.
Look at him, look, see, he's doing better now because of it.
Alright, let's all get in.
Let's all get in.
I have all, what do they have?
What do they use?
He's literally the only person talking.
He's talking to himself.
What do we have?
Oh, they have both supports.
Good job, guys.
You're right.
He does.
He does have double support up.
He's talking to himself.
The voice is in his head.
I'm 96.
This is not the best.
Because I need...
I'm 2% off.
Like, if he ugs, I'm fucked.
I don't trust my team to get off cart.
I hate that
Oh shit, he's giga walking Well, I can't get off
Are they still walking?
Oh shit they are
There you go, I didn't have to never mind you don't need to help me I'm oh this guy also he's raging he's raging There we go Oh, CC, I told you.
I can't leave for it.
This is literally my home now.
It's okay, guys.
They don't need me.
My flake is literally cosmetic.
You know, it should be...
It's okay.
I'm the passenger, princess.
I'm checking on that.
I'm checking.
I don't think I died.
There you go.
Good.
We got closer to me.
We got...
He slowly just walked up to me.
That's good.
That's very helpful.
I was not leaving that cart.
I did it, my one jump.
I jumped.
Oh, they surrendered?
I got
off the guy.
I was like, wait, I jumped.
No.
I thought it was a C9 because I did one little jump.
Lyquist deserves a win.
We hate EU over here.
yeah rigsy i go back to eating you
i'm gonna i'm gonna use the bathroom i'll be right back guys
oh my god mega thank you so much for the 200 gifted.
Oh my god.
I wish I could be louder, but I'm so thankful.
I'm really thankful.
So thank you so much, Mega.
We're the 200 gifted, man.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah, that's a lot.
That's a lot.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying it.
I'm glad you've been enjoying the stream.
Bro, GG's at the lot.
Oh, wait.
Is that the Widowmaker guy?
Is that the guy that was, like, talking to himself?
Talking to his the voices.
Bro, when you were like, guys, what all do we have?
What up?
And no replies.
Like, you're right, guys.
They have a rock, you know.
Like, no, the comms are good.
It's just funny.
Your voices told you what else they had.
you're right guys you're right they have rocket all and i'm like who's right who told you that who fucking told you they had rocket all
yeah he's yeah he'd be the perfect deadpool player he was talking to us the chat
all right i think what time is it now okay eight Hmm...
Alright.
How many... Okay, I'll do one...
Okay, we'll do LG.
LG and then we swap Swap the Street Fighter.
Back to our real main game.
See, I'm a good guy who occasionally- See, I'm a good guy.
This is my favorite pro- Alright.
Back to my hobby.
But never mind, I guess.
Which hero do you think you'll need to...
No, Rove, then...
Fucking Torch?
What are we?
Season 3?
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Now, who am I gonna vanish from this match?
Alright.
I'm surprised we're playing, um, Torch.
In this yellow?
Oh wait, no, specific... No, actually, it never...
mind in this yellow we definitely would play torch all right after this game we swapped the street fighter or we could do street fighter later okay i accidentally might have put uh we'll do it we'll do like i'm now 30 minutes to an hour street fighter that's fine yeah and it banned torch in this yellow where are we I don't know.
I don't know if I want to play Honda or Eve.
I just don't know.
I don't know what I want to do.
Okay, if they have dive, I'm getting off of Luna.
You see the Mecca's Zangief skin?
Nothing will ever be as good as vanilla Zangief.
I think his OG form was just peak Zangief.
You can't improve on.
You can't improve on what's perfect.
already and
when they start changing their zangif colors they're not real zangif mains why would you ever want to change how he looks like when he's perfect already yeah for his lord for my loyal fans this is not what the fans want
oh yeah when i tried zangif with the king mod it was not good like i i didn't know how to play the game And I did it for the tournament, right?
I was like, guys, I put on the mod for my tournament.
Like, on day...
Like, I didn't practice with it.
I was like, guys, it's gonna be so funny.
And then I did it on day one of the tournament.
And I was like, okay, guys, I think I gotta turn this mod off.
Yeah, I was like, guys, I didn't even test.
Okay, we're changing.
We're playing Nviz.
Okay, we're playing Nviz.
I've seen all I needed to see.
I've seen everything I need to see here.
This is that.
Yeah.
I'm playing Animal Crossing.
I've seen enough.
I might not be able to play this character, but I am not playing just against that.
Yeah, that's not happening.
We're not.
We're not getting dope tonight.
I think we're still going to get dope, though.
This is not, might not be, like, the best.
It's because I don't know, technically, I don't know how to play, Jeff.
Oh, shit.
It's not fair.
He gets, they get to dive.
I get whatever the fuck comp I got.
What kind of comp is this?
Because I wish I was rocket.
And I wish I was rocket.
It'd be so much nicer right now.
The thing is, I don't play Jeff enough to know what the fuck I'm doing.
We're like half-dived, too.
That's the thing.
God damn it.
That's the worst part.
Panther literally counters, Jeff.
And because we're playing Animal Crossing.
Alright.
Just swim away.
We have six alts.
Surely we could do something with that, right?
Just swim away.
Are you stupid?
It's just that easy.
Hey, guys.
Can we use, like, any of our own?
I'm too scared to use Oh my Oh my god Okay maybe
Oh my god Oh my god okay I wanted to get the The mantis but he went on the platform It's okay wait we win this Guys we did it
Planned.
It disoriented them.
My alt did it, guys.
My alt made them so confused, and I did that.
I want to break this, but whatever.
It was all me.
Look, guys, I know how to play.
I don't know how to play, Jeff.
But, like, if I play any other character, I'm not going to be alive.
only character that can live the longest on which is not very long which is the sad part i feel like i'm in eu right now hey yes oh hey oh nice you just yeah goodbye me and the raccoon having our own little adventure see guys i'm learning I didn't, because I don't know how.
I'm learning how to play Jeff in rank, guys.
It's not the best option, but that's what I always deal.
That's right, Jeff.
That's right, Hulk.
Can't smash me.
It's honestly not smart to learn this in rank, but that's how I learn every support, to be fair.
Oh, that's awkward.
Nice.
They're real okay?
I think so.
He's fine, right?
Get it?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's my bad.
Oh, shit.
Hey, guys.
Wait, what?
Wait, he lived?
Oh, ha!
Oh shit.
I'm learning.
I'm figuring it out live.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm actually...
Wait, I'm carrying.
Oh my god, I got it.
I'm actually figuring it out.
The juice.
I did it.
I unlocked my third eye.
I unlocked my third.
Hi, bro.
Hi, Jeff.
I'm cooking right now.
The first zoning out, the second clutch out.
There you go.
That's right, guys.
Look at that.
Okay, I'll show you my Jeff hours.
I read this game.
I'll show you guys why this is a huge accomplishment.
I hate you.
When you're escaping and quickly look down Like this Oh like that Oh my god that's too much brainpower I can't make that natural
See this is how little I play Jeff
Oh just without jumping okay Wait, we're running triple.
We're doing it, guys.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, they're not living.
Oh my god, I'm fucking slowly.
I'm swimming away.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we did it.
I don't know about Venom, though, but we did.
did it.
Oh my god, I just got here!
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
Bro, what?
Oh, now he swaps off.
Okay, Dylan.
Now you swap off fucking matches and, and ultra.
I hate that.
That's like one of my biggest pet peeves when like, one tricks, they don't swap off their one tricks on um against uh on your team but they swap it off when they're against you that's like one of my biggest pet peeves i don't know when to use this up honestly oh yes that's a lot of dead people right now oh okay i thought i was getting hit
Don't worry, guys.
Wait, they're not in dive anymore.
Wait, I can get off this fucking character.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna...
Either we're gonna die or this is gonna be clutch, guys.
At least I live.
Look, it's neither.
I lived.
Guys, I lived, though.
Okay, I'm alive.
Oh, God.
See, it's neither.
Okay, I gotta swap out because they're not in dive.
Technically, they're not in dive anymore.
Oh, shit.
Where am I?
Oh my god!
What the fuck is going on?
Oh shit!
They're punching the flying man!
Oh my god, they're punching me!
Whoa!
That's okay.
I spit on them.
Whatever happened to that girl after she did her fucking crypto scam?
Her crypto girl?
Like, is she alive?
I mean she's like a like a billion a millionaire or some shit now I will not be surprised but like is she like Like what happened?
And he she like rug pulled and disappeared
They got her they what yeah, they got her What do you mean they got her?
I love you know, I would say ted the tv show is surprisingly really good Wait,
she did Fortnite Fridays?
How the fuck did she get in contact with her?
Like, I swear you was, like, super...
Hey, guys, there's just this...
Can't get me if I'm in need...
Oh my god, oh my god, it's a real...
It's over.
Y'all just...
They could just do that, walk away from my ult.
That's crazy.
That should be illegal.
How could we be able to do that?
You could just fucking do that?
Oh, but when I walk away from my ult...
I still get caught.
How is that possible?
Hey guys, how come like we just let them do that?
Okay, there's nothing I could do for that.
I'm sorry.
Jesus Christ.
Look at that, I'm carrying!
It's just like Rocky.
It's just like Rocket, guys!
Oh my god, it's just like him.
Same concept, different animal.
Wait, winnable.
Look at that, guys.
I can learn.
High ground, who would have thought?
High ground equals win.
GG's.
That was last year.
oh my god yeah even better because i can do damage too guys okay okay let me i learned just enough okay let me show you guys all right where is statistics okay okay we don't look at that we don't look at still figuring it out okay surprisingly i have a higher win rate on my other support okay i have 100 okay we don't we don't look at that but okay i have four point i have more hours on sidelog than i do on jeff look at it like it's like 200 hours on luna and then all my other supports and jeff with the 4.1 hours but look there's more all right 1.2 hours on jeff one minute on jeff wait where is jeff jeff is not even here zero hours on jeff another zero uh five minutes no one minute that's fucking huge toky oh yeah zero on everything zero on jeff oh look oh 2.6 2.6 that's when i guys look see that's when i started playing look okay 2.6 hours you see that right 2.6 hours 2.6 hours 4.1 hours so 50 of my jeff gameplay has been last season has been this actually not even 50 70 of my hours
have been on season four and my total is 4.1
I can learn how to play Chep.
I did it.
That's when the buffs came in.
That's when I opened my third eye.
That's crazy.
I learned how to dodge.
The Animal Crossing meta.
All right, let's go swap games.
Do I have Street Fighter download?
Let me check.
All right, goodbye rivals category.
I haven't swapped a category before.
Goodbye.
I can't hold your category up anymore.
You're on your own.
own.
You're on your own now.
I've done my job.
All right.
Gotta learn today.
Let's see.
I'm pretty sure I have it downloaded.
Guys, I didn't install Street Fighter.
Okay, guys, JK, I didn't.
I'll call it here.
All right, guys.
Anyway, thank you all for coming i really appreciate this 100 gigabytes chat i thought i installed it um we're gonna call it here i have another stream today but thank you all for coming if you're new here my name is toky bird please vote for me nominate me for a marvel rival streamer we do exclamation point vote it's why i've been doing a lot of rival streams um lady but you could nominate me as best marvel rival streamer it would mean a a lot.
Someone, people could look at the characters like, where did she come from?
But yes, I would really appreciate it if you scroll all the way down here and then nominate Doki Bird.
This is my campaign to get nominated.
It would really, really mean a lot.
And thank you all for watching.
Thank you for all the raids.
Thank you, Mega, for all the gifted subs.
That was crazy.
Thank you so much for the insane support mega i really really do appreciate it um and uh thank you for all the um um follows the subs the rates if you want to check me out please feel free to follow me on uh youtube because that's where i do most of my streams um i actually am mostly um uh youtube streamer but i do stream here what because i'm trying to campaign for usually do guerrilla stuff here or my sponsor streams here um um but i really appreciate everyone it really does mean so much um and if you want to support me via other means feel free to uh uh you know check out my merch exclamation point merch and i also tweet out whenever i stream on twitch uh first vtuber stream and it's already an ad bro i'm booked to end bro anyway guys anyways i'm gonna head off now as always everybody say hi to pause to check it out and move around to get that blood flowing any of you uh stay up for me head to bed because uh you deserve it uh i am gonna have to make my schedule now uh because i got
confirmation of all of my stuff my schedule streams anyway bye bye guys bye yeah i don't know what i'm gonna rate so i don't know we'll figure it out bye bye